there's no time
[Music]
13. o'clock
[Music]
hey you guys what's going on
nothing much obviously what is this
thing that's like in the corner of the
oh that's that oh it's good anyway yeah
it's just I don't know it's just
bothering me and but I can't move it
though
it's being a butthole okay yeah that
fixed it okay it's just like a little
piece of the wire Oh wrong ball today
I'm not even not even gonna bring my hat
oh hardcore you're not even gonna do you
you could do like I got a beard now so I
don't need the Hat you could do the
Mozart wig like to kind of go I don't
know I know it's a little old for like
the Victorian era but yeah
if I go get a wig I'm gonna get Conan
he's gonna go get the code yeah yeah
well then it would match my hair because
this is this is the black one yeah
that's what Danny rolling said white wig
that's what I thought too because that's
kind of like the only historical person
that you have I ain't [ __ ] with that
don't you have one don't you have one
that's a mullet yeah yeah I got all that
[ __ ] I thought yeah I got everything
I thought you had a K-pop wig I got all
I got [ __ ] I got oh they're out of
the world
wigs over there like a world of wigs I
could just I could I could manifest as
any character I want I need a [ __ ] L
Ron Hubbard wig that'd be awesome yeah
yeah I could go [ __ ] break off into
Ron Hubbard because Zach said I need
elrond needs to be in every show
but
I don't know if I could manage that I
mean you probably could if you could
just do it briefly we could have like L
Rons what's just kind of like on the old
shows we're used to ask btk's opinion
about various serial killers we could
ask L Ron Hubbard his opinions about
whatever uh topic it is that we're
talking about David's in what's up
what's up Dave hello YouTube out of work
and you're my drive home okay good is
that Stone Cold Steve Austin yeah
yeah I'm [ __ ] oh yeah yeah
this [ __ ] our mom's [ __ ] with me yeah
I got bad Trend cough and uh yeah he's
just hacking and hacking yeah all the
time you're gonna hack up along yeah the
[ __ ] that I'm on is known for that and
I'm also starting to get weird side
effects that's known for like thinking
that your girlfriend's cheating on you
and getting paranoid yeah he was telling
me about that earlier I'm like have you
been is that why you've been acting so
weird and like crabby like this dude
that people are talking about you you
know what I mean and [ __ ] that you
know what I mean that they don't like
you you know it's just you start getting
[ __ ] hyper masculine behavior and
[ __ ] you're like oh she's gonna dump me
I I'm gonna have to get me another
girlfriend and dump her before she dumps
me and then we that way I can save face
and because we can't dump each other
side because the [ __ ] Spirits won't
[ __ ] work out like that you know what
I mean it's just and it's like this
weird
and I I was prepared for it you know
what I mean because all the research
says the dudes that said be prepared for
that during the [ __ ] adjustment phase
and it just creeped up on me so slowly I
didn't realize I was doing it it started
to do it slowly over a period of above
I I noticed it like a week ago but it
was probably doing it for two weeks
he only just told me about it today
though yeah I was like I kind of wish
yeah because then you get paranoid you
can't you're like well I can't tell her
because uh you know what I mean she'll
dump me yeah that's exactly what that's
exactly so it's a vicious yeah yeah so I
was like yeah I kind of wish
and [ __ ] and like insecurities and [ __ ]
you know it's like it's weird
but they just said it's like that drugs
are hell of a drugless drugs are a hell
of a drug it's not really a drug it's a
hormone it's like a copy of a [ __ ]
bull testosterone all right so I'm
[ __ ] acting like a damn Minotaur she
thought I was joking no yeah I thought
you were a human I thought you were like
making a reference to BTK because that's
what he used to say it was no he was
like a Minotaur no guys use tram balloon
but it wasn't does it develop for
[ __ ] humans it was developed for
cattle
see I'm kind of I'm just gonna like not
it's like the Holy Grail
it burns fat off you every time somebody
says that I remember that book that I
read about that dude from like the 19th
century or early 20th century that was
like um sowing goat testicles into dudes
yeah scrutes like that
which is also not a good idea
Pro tip dollar for dollar it it it it it
[ __ ] yields the greatest [ __ ]
results because it's cheap it comes from
the cattle industry
so and a human dose is tidy compared to
what they'd give to a cow or like a
[ __ ] bull you know or whatever but it
just makes them [ __ ] big and plump
and [ __ ] Burns all the fat off and
they're probably working they're
probably crazy too about their
girlfriends they're all cheating on each
other
but they can't do anything about it you
know they can't talk that funny until
they think of like a bowl being like
you're like what's that [ __ ] that's
cheating on me
they're thinking about it like look at
all the cows yeah she's plotting against
me
slowly
and it it crept up on me and I went oh
I'm doing it this is what they were
talking about yeah yeah like I saw
you've been acting weird the last yeah
it shouldn't get any worse I didn't want
to say anything yeah because I wasn't
sure if I was imagined it yeah
like he's like I said it's a vicious
cycle it's a vicious cycle I'm halfway
through it so it shouldn't get any worse
and I'm not increasing any dosages so it
should just run like this or it will
resolve because the guys say most dudes
[ __ ] who take it for long period of
time so all that stuff goes away because
it just they end up adapting to it and
it's all in the the glitches all get
resolved out over over a period of time
because it's glitches
what it is like hormonal signals being
confused macedo said wait until the
neighbor's dog starts talking to you
uh-oh yeah no you know what
you know it's real yeah that's probably
not I came to her way that I said
[ __ ] I know this isn't really
happening it's just what it's telling me
it's happened it's like the Poltergeist
telling me that it's happening like that
it's not true though man said you could
man said I could
which man is [ __ ] with you yeah that
goes back to a lot of these weird cases
we talked about these dudes these serial
killers and [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
and I said earlier before I said I'd
like to see their blood results because
they might be some kind of a mutant
human being a mutant dude and maybe he's
not producing testosterone maybe he's
producing a a testosterone like
substance that's more like Tran you know
which would [ __ ] you up and it turns him
into like a cycle turn them into a
[ __ ] psycho yeah you take a lot of
this it will
there's dudes that have done it but
they're taking a [ __ ] a [ __ ] ton because
some dudes get into this damn spiral
where they're like yeah I feel good but
then I'm [ __ ] angry and everybody's
talking about me so I have to [ __ ]
buck up and get even more Fierce so I'm
gonna take more to defend myself next
thing you know he's taking like [ __ ]
six times what he should be and that
[ __ ] goes off
you know because he's got nobody there
to [ __ ] tell him to stop
yeah that's I was just gonna think that
Chris uh how do you pronounce his last
name Benoit been Ben
yeah he was on that yeah on Trend it was
true yeah but I don't think that's what
it wasn't just that he had a lot of
multiple head injuries yeah that I'm
sure that didn't happen that was more of
it did we ever do a show about that guy
hmm I thought we talked about him much
because remember like for a time we were
just kind of like shorter stories like
before the main thing I thought we
talked about him on one of that but I
could be remembering that they had a
dude here who was the bodybuilder he was
[ __ ] huge and this is just not too
long ago maybe maybe a year ago
he at random attacked a damn family
uh accusing them of keeping a 12 year
old girl or a hostage as some kind of
slave
and he killed the parrots and then
grabbed like the 16 year old daughter
and tortured her to try to find out
where that girl was he was convinced
that they had some girl they didn't know
who he was talking about
yeah and evidently he didn't know them
he saw them or something when he was
driving around and it got into his mind
that they had some girl
uh but I don't know it might have not
just been tread he was on Trend he was
big
um you know you're talking about a dude
two maybe 260 270. who's he the Giant
but he may have had some other mental
problems like he might have had
schizophrenia on top of that there's a
lot of weird [ __ ] that can happen
and I couldn't imagine being
schizophrenic on this
whew
well you know more stories like that
makes me uh happy that I hardly ever go
outside yeah
well you never know it's like most of
the time you're fine but it's just or
like people are fine but uh I meant like
the Royal you like everybody yeah but
most of the time people are fine but you
never know when like some crazy
[ __ ] like that is like looking
at you and I bet they have a sex slave
and they're done yeah I'm just like what
he shows up like a superhero he thinks
he's the Punisher he's got assault rifle
and all kinds of stuff and he's [ __ ]
270 or something
yeah it just [ __ ] crashes down the
door just walks in can you imagine like
just going about your [ __ ] regular
ass day and some big [ __ ] Hall click
comes and he's like you're doing it I'm
just like what yeah and and they had no
idea this dude he asked first he says
give give the girl over and they're like
what girl they need his name and the
girl we don't never heard of that and he
boom he busted and [ __ ] he was
ex-military
Dave is that army if I remember
correctly you guys can look it up we got
to do a show on that crazy people are
crazy many of us here in Florida
well that tracks
he didn't look unusual he just was a big
dude yeah yeah wow Florida man Florida
man Florida man doing the things it
wasn't very old maybe 30. murder Hornet
said Jenny get a gun
[Laughter]
you don't know what kind of stuff I got
I'm more an ax murder kind of yeah but
I'm just I'm just kidding don't take
that out of context uh but yeah so
where do we go from there how do we
segue I'm trying to think of you like
how to segue what this this episode is
about Queen Victoria Queen Victoria this
sounds boring as [ __ ] no it does what is
it what did you tell me sell this show
to me what is exciting about Queen
Victoria why is this why are you why you
gotta why are you gonna put it put me on
the spot I understand why why is this
show gonna be badass oh you're already
beating like no no no okay you're
already being like confrontational it's
gonna be it's gonna be a good show I
thought it was interesting okay I
thought the same thing that you thought
because I was kind of like why I'm
interested in this kind of like
historical kind of stuff but then like
when it won and I was kind of like doing
research about it and I was like well I
don't know how exciting but then I was
reading it I'm like oh actually this is
kind of interesting
yeah it won okay so people voted for
this oh yeah well then we got to give
them what they wanted that's what I'm
saying okay so it's not like I just
pulled it out of my ass like it never
can't tell
I never pulled the topics out of my well
I mean okay I'll go get the video camera
we're gonna see when we can pull that
we're gonna go put that [ __ ] on only
face oh it's gonna be that kind of show
is it okay no I'm just well yeah I'm
just saying that um all right well now
what I do like I said I have I have a
big long list and every time well most
of the time if I remember like most of
the time when people give me a
recommendation for a topic I add it to
the list and then every week I put up a
poll with five different topics that I
take randomly off the list and whichever
one gets the most votes wins so this one
got the most votes like easily I think
the other ones didn't like only got one
vote each or something but this one got
like a bunch of votes and I think like a
bunch of people like uh asked about this
one Zach particularly I think he wanted
people voted for a queen I'm chuckling a
bit more than I should
[Laughter]
no
okay Cuomo
nothing wrong with a bit of cousin
loving right I mean I didn't even
realize I mean I guess I kind of
realized this on some level because I
did learn about this in school but I
didn't even realize that Victoria and
Albert were first cousins I thought they
were second cousins but now they're
first cousins Danny asked me something
no I'm gonna get on it she asked me if
I'd ever put dual sport tires or dirt
tires on my Buell to go off-road with it
yeah I would my SX
one of I got two of them one of them is
is the um the uh built xb9sx city cross
and it's kind of set up as a
kind of like a little dual sport or like
a dirt bike but it's got street tires on
it right now I think I think I've got
um Diablos on there I think no no what
did I have on there I had them I had
Diablos on there for a while but I put
something else on there I forgot what it
was
uh [ __ ] some metzlers I think
but uh no they'd be great with dirt
tires on it
they're dudes that have done it you know
take the s model or the SX model and
then they'll put extended swing arm on
there off of that Dam wait a minute no
it's not the it I was thinking of the SS
model with the [ __ ] extended no it
was extended swing arm I think off of uh
the Ulysses I think it's a little bit
longer by a few inches
I may be wrong about that or something I
thought the I thought that that was a
longer swing arm anyway they would try
to stretch it out a little bit and they
put like a longer travel suspension on
it and they were catching air with it
good air like 10 15 feet
like a dirt bike and it was a 1200 so
yeah it can do it does it well
make a good Mad Max motorcycle
air cooling you know you can't damage it
no radiators to damage it
lion X Warrior says no we heard you
you're a mad Ax Murderer chick LOL yeah
well you know
Bob Apple said do a Robert the doll
episode did we do a Robert the doll
episode or am I high I never heard of
Robert the Doll it's Key West right
that's like that supposedly haunted doll
I don't know if we did an entire episode
but I think we did talk about now I
gotta look it up yeah now I gotta look
it up because I'm pretty sure because I
remember doing research for that
but I don't remember like what context
that was macedo said they all colluded
to pick the topic Tom would least like
[Laughter]
yeah yeah probably trying to get well no
I mean the thing about it is that I mean
there's a lot of interest like I left
out because you know if you go to like
the thing there's you know this all
these intricacies of like all the uh you
know uh foreign kind of stuff they were
getting and I kind of left a lot of that
out because like I thought that was kind
of like not all that exciting
um honestly I was kind of more
interested in
her and like her
her influence on society like the way
and kind of like the way that she was
brought up and stuff like that like I
found that stuff a lot more interesting
than just kind of like your
run-of-the-mill Palace type of stuff
like hey we went to France and visited
this king or whatever like that stuff's
not interesting but yeah like some of
the other stuff I thought was like
pretty interesting
and especially like how influential she
was the weird thing about Victoria is
that she's probably well I don't even
know probably she's definitely one of
the most influential monarchs I mean for
Christ's sake there's still like a whole
era named after her that people like
still talk about the weird thing about
it though is that despite that it's
almost kind of like she's simultaneously
and paradoxically
like the most influential thing from
that period like the most influential
person from that period but also not
because she really didn't give a [ __ ]
about I mean during her Reign which was
very long you know they had the
Industrial Revolution they had like all
these like this big cultural upheaval in
technology and all these other things
and she really didn't seem all that
interested in that kind of stuff
and it's just really interesting to me
like just the whole juxtaposition of her
not really being into progress or
innovation or technology or anything
like that and yet simultaneously being
associated with one of the most like
biggest cultural upheavals like in
history like I don't know like that's
like really weird to me
and she was also kind of like really
instrumental in the way that the royal
family is perceived nowadays as a more
like ceremonial type of thing rather
than an actual like political force
um she was actually instrumental in that
too not on purpose necessarily but
that's just kind of like the way it
happened so we'll kind of get into that
as well so if that's why she's
influential I think and it wasn't even
necessarily because of anything she did
directly necessarily but it was just
kind of like a lot of things that
conspired you know what I mean
but I just I don't know I thought it was
kind of like a kind of interesting
uh yeah Baba said oh okay I mean maybe
we didn't but I could have sworn that we
did that we talked about Robert the doll
at some point like it was a while back
but I don't remember if we did a show
about haunted dolls or if we did a show
about like Florida hauntings and we
talked about it on there because I know
it wasn't a whole show but I think we
talked about it like in the context of
like another show
maybe it was like scary Florida [ __ ] or
I don't know I don't remember what it
was
yeah Danny Rowling said yeah you did an
episode of the doll and other cursed
objects yeah maybe it was a cursed
object show that's right we did do a
cursed object show and I think we talked
about that we talked about maybe like
the dibbuk box and like some other [ __ ]
I think I don't know we've done so many
shows this is episode 321 of just the
regular show I mean that's not even
counting like all the movie reviews and
[ __ ] like that
okay yeah Denny Rowling said episode 209
creepy Florida Legends okay thank you
for looking that up yeah because I was
sure that I had done it on some kind of
like
Anthology type show like where we had a
lot of different topics
so thank you for looking that up I was
asking I was answering a private
message from
um these Nest or [ __ ] murder horn
it's a Santa and uh yeah it's tread
that's what we were talking about you
must have joined late as Trent it's bad
I I don't think I'll do it again
it's uh is very effective
it's cost effective it's it works it's
working fast
it's a blend of testosterone masteron
which is a kind of like a it's known for
slamming and kind of burning fat off and
trend
and it's in the right ratios where you
can just shoot it all at once but no
it's it's miserable I don't like it at
all all the other ones I've ever taken
[ __ ] were great they just you make
you feel great you know
this is the no don't do it
no don't do it make it real paranoid you
lose a lot of sleep
you don't really feel strong you are
strong but you don't feel it uh
you feel kind of crappy sometimes it
resolves itself and it gets better and
then the side effects kind of go away
but it doesn't for everybody so I'm just
going to do this one bottle and when
it's over I don't think I'm gonna do any
more
I'm not sure it's worth the trouble
because there are other ones I know work
that you feel great on them they cost
more yeah I mean that's what I told you
it's like it's really not worth it if
it's just gonna make you feel like [ __ ]
all the time that's really no way to
live yeah you know yeah unless it evens
out and becomes like
good but it's not good so far I'm about
halfway through it
um
but no there are other ones that cost
more you got to take more over a longer
period of time but you feel great
through the whole thing you know
positive mental state uh
feel energetic you know what I mean good
sleep and happy you know but no
no don't do this one
not unless you're really [ __ ] serious
you have to put on a bunch of muscle
real quick like five pounds or two
pounds a month you could probably you
might be able to do it you know if
you're eating right working enough
but maybe more but I don't know it would
be dose dependent I'm not taking that
much and it's still it's hell I don't
like it at all
just getting through it that's all
lanex Warrior said Queen Victoria was an
obese shag-a-thon she had a scotch
Soldier lover yep that's right and a
subcontinental Indian military lover she
was all about getting it on yeah we're
gonna get into that I mean rumored but
probably this was after Albert died
because I kind of feel like she's famous
for mourning like the rest of her life
after Albert died which she did but she
wouldn't sell a bit after that I don't
think you know what I mean so uh so
there so there was that and uh yeah she
only got fat later
um mostly after I think after Albert
died like she just kind of like holed up
in the palace and like just started
eating bon bons and stuff and then got
like super fat and plus I didn't know
this about her either but she was super
short four foot eleven she was a tiny
tiny little thing but they said even
though she was that small
um they said that she just kind of had a
very very Grand presence even though she
was a little tiny thing and I mean when
she was young she was slim obviously but
yeah she uh she got like pretty heavy
later on like after Albert she was cute
when she was young too from what I
remember she was yeah well like I said
she ascended to the throne when she was
really young uh and there's like
paintings of her there's paintings of
her from like when she was youthful you
know what I mean but I think people
remember her nowadays as like the old
fat lady yeah is this one that just died
no that's no that's Elizabeth it's
Elizabeth that's Elizabeth is actually
Victoria's great great granddaughter I
was thinking of uh Elizabeth right the
one that just died yeah yeah like in in
the 60s or 70s she was super cute
Victoria was cute when she was young too
at least according to the paintings I
mean there were photographs of her
from her later life yeah uh but you know
they didn't have photography I don't
think what she started out but yeah I
think these are all bad people though
I got a feeling that they're yeah I mean
I feel they're basically gangsters I
mean the thing about Victoria
um I think her greatest sin was not I
don't think she was a bad person
um she seemed like
uh she seemed like a very honest person
she seemed like a very forthright person
but I think she was very
sheltered
and I think that she didn't really
I guess because she was privileged and
she didn't really have to I think she
didn't really care all that much about
the plight of regular people I was under
the impression that the men from the
from all these royal families doesn't
even matter if they're British or not if
you're in a royal family the men are
scum they're just you know always under
that impression yeah the kind of dudes
that would just pull up and grab your
wife and throw in the back seat and [ __ ]
her and just then drop her off a couple
blocks away they were like I mean I'm
sure probably most of them were like
yeah I mean I'm sure there were
exceptions like I said I don't think
Victoria didn't strike me at at least
what I read about her she didn't strike
me as being like particularly shitty or
autocratic or anything like that I think
she was just kind of more sheltered like
I said and privileged more than anything
else she'd never lived like a regular
person
um so she couldn't really relate to
regular people but I don't think that
she was like mean on purpose I think
like she did the best that she could
under the circumstances
um but some of her views were kind of
weird but not as weird as like some
other people's at the time I guess so I
don't know so like I said I kind of
found that sort of interesting about her
as well but you can kind of see where
she was coming from you know yeah
Rickshaw said I watched the Queen's
funeral that's Elizabeth uh not a
royalist but it was pretty epic yeah I
didn't see it actually but
yeah and I didn't realize I mean I
realized that Victoria and Elizabeth II
were related but I didn't realize that
Elizabeth II is was Victoria's great
great granddaughter and actually
Elizabeth II is now uh the longest
reigning monarch 70 years almost 71
years previous to that Victoria was the
longest running she she reigned for 63
years so she had the record until
Elizabeth came along and uh went many
years more but yeah so there's that and
again like I said Victoria probably one
of the most influential
definitely one of the most influential
in Britain uh and you know probably most
one of the most influential in the
western world as well but yeah four foot
eleven I didn't even realize that she
doesn't she doesn't look that short in
the paintings like
uh yeah and her and Albert also had uh
nine kids now a bunch of them died like
they all got to adulthood but some of
them like died pretty young
so are we ready to get into ooh ooh okay
before we do that I wanted to give a
thanks I don't think DJ Maniac is here
but I wanted to thank DJ Maniac he sent
me uh he had messaged me this about this
uh Anthology Book that looks like it's
called found and it's like all about
it's all found footage like but they're
stories you know what I mean like
written stories and the Pat the book
cover is like so cool and it looks like
an old VHS and he bought it for me
he bought me the the ebook and like it's
so it's in my Kindle library so thank
you very much for that I'll probably be
reading it soon and reviewing it for the
next few weeks I'm going to be doing
um like Halloween books like I found
some uh some like Halloween Anthology
stories that are like books that I
wanted to cover like for my uh book
review thing so I'll be doing that like
the next few weeks I think the next one
that I'm gonna do is called literally
dead and it's um all Halloween stories I
think but that's the next one I'm gonna
do but I'll probably do it like early in
November like after Halloween is over so
there's that
um yeah so are we ready to get into this
or are you gonna like talk about
not good Tammy said uh the movie
Victoria and Abdul yeah we'll get into
that like toward the end it was a pretty
good film don't know how much of it was
true yeah I think a lot of it was
supposition they do actually know a lot
about Victoria's life because she was
um she kept a diary like pretty much
every day from like the time she was a
teenager until she pretty much she died
so
um so yeah they they have like records
of how she actually like felt about [ __ ]
and everything like that she was very
very like good about writing everything
down like how she felt about stuff and
what happened and everything so they
actually do know a lot about her life
but some stuff I kind of think that her
daughter
uh Beatrice I think one of her daughters
like after her after Victoria died like
Beatrice she was like the literary
executor and I think that she
transcribed some of the stuff and she
maybe
um
like didn't transcribe some of the stuff
that she thought would be embarrassing
like to her mom and I think she burned
some of the [ __ ] also some of the stuff
has been recovered but
we don't really know but there but there
are rumors that not only that after
Albert died and like I said it's not
that scandalous because you know her
husband was dead she was a widow
um that she hooked up with uh the
manservant that Scottish dude uh John
Brown and later on after he died then
she maybe was hooking up with um another
quote unquote manservant who she called
her secretary like an Indian like a guy
from India that went with her everywhere
so maybe I I don't know but you know
that's that's what the rumor was and I
would find it
I mean and like I said you can't you
can't blame the woman you know what I
mean it's like she
which you didn't have any
responsibilities come on she had money
well and that's the thing and Company
yeah [ __ ] she's gonna just be locked up
in the house anyway well yeah and the
thing about her and particularly like
we'll get into in a second like the way
that she was brought up I mean she was
brought up like from birth they knew
that she was probably eventually going
to be Queen one day so I mean she had a
very lonely life so she seemed to like
really latch on to
people like to have because she knew
that there was a lot of people she
couldn't trust and stuff like that
because of how her family like was so if
she found somebody she liked that was
like honest with her and was trustworthy
then she would like latch onto that
person and like be super super loyal to
them because she didn't have much of
that in her life I heard there's a
Japanese Imperial family is even worse
at the dam their versions of like the
empress
I think the last one that they had or
maybe two of them back that she was
insane she went crazy because they made
them do the same ritual things over and
over again they're basically prisoners
they can't go anywhere they're gonna
stay in that damn Palace that's what I
mean I kind of yeah I mean I kind of
feel like she didn't really want to be
in there yeah I don't know what happened
to her they kind of silenced it she
probably crazy in there still
that's the thing about I mean being in a
royal family it's like it must be nice
to have all that money and like not have
to worry about that so you know that's
cool but also being in the public eye
but you can't like I said this is kind
of about like the same thing as being
like super super famous which yeah the
money is awesome but you can't have
anything approaching a normal life which
would probably drive you a little bit
crazy after a while I think in Japan
they can't leave the palace
yeah so they're prisoners see that's
[ __ ] up yeah that's [ __ ] up I mean
it's nice as the palace is yeah
eventually you're kind of like can I
just walk down to 7-Eleven or something
like that and it's like they won't even
let you know that's like she was a
normal woman before she went in there
she was just married into it and she
went crazy this is back in the I think
in the 80s or the 90s you guys can look
up what happened to her Events maybe
they retired her or got rid of her I
don't know but she was like it was well
known even in the Japanese press that
she was like
losing her Marbles and [ __ ] trying to
escape most people would lose their
marbles in that situation I think she
would just cry constantly yeah you know
I mean I just I can't imagine I just
can't imagine
Tammy said she that she only watched
that movie Victorian Abdul because Eddie
Izzard was in it oh well now I
definitely have to watch it because I
love him Rickshaw said Queen Elizabeth
II met 13 different U.S presidents
damn
that is [ __ ] that's a lot that's
I can't even imagine like being a queen
or being like something for that long 70
[ __ ] years yeah [ __ ] man I don't want
to do anything for 70 years [ __ ] that
like I said money's nice I'm sure but
not being in the public eye not being I
you know I'd rather be rich and not
famous I don't want to be famous that
would suck
because you can't go any place
you know yeah can't go anyplace
all right so let's get into this and
hopefully Tom won't get too bored
no it's interesting you know it's you
know about history and [ __ ] like that
you can just kind of it's like like I
said I tried to stick to like a lot of
the stuff that I thought was interesting
like a lot of the cultural kind of stuff
that was going on like her upbringing
and everything like that so you know I I
left out a lot of kind of more intricate
kind of stuff that I didn't think was
all that exciting but you know what I
mean
so all right so Victoria was actually
Victoria was actually not her first name
which is another thing I didn't know
her first name is actually alexandrina
she was named after one of her
godparents who was Czar Alexander the
first of Russia Victoria was actually
her middle name I guess or her second
name because Victoria was also her mom's
name so that's what they uh named her so
she was actually born at Kensington
Palace uh in May of
1819. now Victoria's grandfather was
George III uh who at that time like when
she was a kid was the reigning King of
England so her dad was Prince Edward who
was the Duke of Kent and her mom
Victoria was actually German
um and she became like The Duchess of
Kent obviously when she married Prince
Edward now her dad Prince Edward was
actually the next in line to be king but
he died in 1820 when Victoria was still
a baby like she was less than a year old
a week after that her grandfather died
who was King and he was succeeded by his
eldest son who was that who would have
been George IV
so Victoria at that point even though
she was still a baby was third in line
to the throne
after like two other I think there were
uncles Frederick and William
II had a second daughter named princess
Elizabeth of Clarence she was she died
at 12 weeks so she would have been the
thing she hadn't died as a baby but then
you know so Victoria's fourth in line
but then she went back to third now the
Duke of York died in 1827 and then
George IV died in 1830 so then the
throne goes to their next surviving
brother who was William so William was
King uh and then Victoria I think she
was 13 years old she became what they
called the air presumptive so it's like
basically they think she's gonna be the
she's gonna be the air they're like yeah
pretty much so she grew up her pretty
much her whole entire life like I said I
think she was 13 when she became the air
presumptive so her whole entire life
they knew that eventually she was going
to be you know the next queen or
whatever
so Victoria
um actually later described her
childhood as Melancholy that was the
word that she used
her mom uh The Duchess of Kent whose
name was also Victoria was
um
I don't want to say tyrannical uh some
of the things I said said she was
overprotective but I think it goes Way
Beyond overprotective the thing about
her mom The Duchess of Kent was that she
had this uh consort comptroller dude
named Sir John Conroy everybody thinks
that probably Conroy and the mom were
[ __ ] I mean probably they were
but Conroy sounds like a real douche
so Conroy and the mom came up with this
thing called the Kensington system
that's what they called it and it was
this big elaborate set of rules that uh
that Victoria little Victoria had to
abide by basically she was not allowed
to hang out with other kids
she wasn't allowed to hang out with
anybody that her mom or Conroy did not
approve of which was pretty much
everybody
um including like her own father's
family so you know there was that
um they wouldn't she had to sleep in the
same room with her mom
um and basically during play time she
was only allowed to play with dolls or
like her dog they weren't allowed they
didn't let her play with other kids or
anything like that she was very very
very isolated weird and she was home
tutored so she didn't even get to like
go to school or if she didn't get to
hang out with any kids her own age what
is it they didn't want her to know well
one of the things they were trying to do
and Conroy in particular uh he spent a
lot of her teenage years basically like
he would give her tasks which were
essentially impossible and then when she
couldn't do them he would say stuff to
her like well you're obviously too
stupid to be Queen
what they were trying to do was they
were essentially like trying to break
her down
um psychologically so that she would be
weak and easy for them to control
because they knew that eventually she
might be the Monarch one day and they
wanted to make her a puppet is
essentially what they were doing I mean
it's you know I don't know if they'd
come out and admit that but that seems
like what they were trying to do
um you know because she was just a kid
right so they thought if we can just
make her insecure and doubt herself and
like yeah probably backfired uh it did
it's not how the human mind works and
they have willpower yeah thank you Emily
you guys should review Jacob's Ladder if
y'all ever get a chance we did Jacob's
Ladder did we not I thought we did I'm
pretty sure we'd it's I mean we've done
so many movies but I'm pretty sure we
did Jacob's Ladder but I think it was
like a long time ago if we didn't we
will do it yeah write it down I will but
I'm pretty sure we've done it but but
we'll check so yeah I just don't
remember when it was it was it was a
while back
like I said we've done so many movies
that I I forget which ones we've done
you know what I mean
so
um yeah so that's basically what they
would do they would just kind of like
they isolated her from everybody and
told her how stupid she was all the time
because they thought that that would
like break her down eventually
so 1830
um the mom and Conroy the douche uh took
Victoria on a tour across England now
she was still only a teenager at this
point uh so they basically went all
around like a different towns and [ __ ]
like that and they did this like a few
years in succession like they did it
again In 1832 like 1833 blah blah blah
now uh King William was still King at
this point and he got super super pissy
because every time they did one of these
tours
um everybody really liked Victoria like
you know all the public and everybody
that she met was like really really
Charmed by her like I said she was you
know pretty young at this point like 13
14 15 something like that and everybody
really liked her and the King got really
butt hurt because he's like oh this
seems more like um she's more like my
equal or my rival rather than my you
know Heir Apparent or whatever so he was
getting like really butt hurt about it
and uh so there was that and then
Victoria also she didn't particularly
like uh doing these tours either because
um you know one she had to hang out with
her mom and Conroy uh you know she who
she hated and also she's like it was
just really really like constant
traveling and constant like meeting all
these people and [ __ ] like that and it
just wore her out and she didn't really
like it so she tried to get out of it
um you know what I mean and she's
basically like hey the king doesn't even
want me here he's like constantly
pissing and moaning uh but her mom was
like oh [ __ ] him he's just jealous of
you because everybody likes you better
than him and uh basically forced her to
keep going with it
now during one of these tours in uh 1835
Victoria got really really sick like
some kind of fever I don't know if it
was typhoid or something like that now
Conroy because he's a peach he's a real
prize he basically said oh cut it out
you're faking you know
um but then they were like oh no she
actually really is sick after they
determined that she really was sick then
they went in there because she was I
think she was 16 at this point when she
was like really ill and vulnerable the
mom and Conroy both go in there and like
started badgering her to make Conroy her
private secretary like make him work for
her like while she was sick lets you do
it do it do it like sign this contract
sign this contract [ __ ] like that
um and basically she was I mean good for
her she was only 16 at the time and was
sick and was probably like you know
tired of all this [ __ ] touring but
she was like absolutely not because she
[ __ ] hated that guy and matter of
fact one of the first things she did
when they made her Queen was she banned
him from her presence which I thought
which I thought that was like super
awesome yeah
yeah like I said
so I'd have some Ford I mean she
she got to be Queen like very young and
she was very inexperienced but you know
she and she kind of got pushed around
some but she absolutely would not let
them push her around because she
her mom and her Conroy um she actually
really hated them she always hated
Conroy um and actually she didn't really
reconcile with her mom until like way
later because she blamed them for like
[ __ ] up her entire it reminds me of
something Nichi said one of his books I
can paraphrase it
if you take a kid and you just let them
grow wild
they tend to be weak and then and
self-destructive
but if you take a kid and then wait them
weigh them down
with a bunch of [ __ ] nonsense and
restrictions like religion and
discipline
it takes them a while but they'll
eventually strip all that stuff off of
them and think their way out of it and
what you have when you're done is a
[ __ ] well-defended dragon
and that's what they did they just
didn't realize that that's what happened
you know what I mean they didn't read
Nietzsche
you know that can happen yeah some kids
some kids it might break them but the
ones that it doesn't break you're just
gonna make a well-defended dragon
you know yeah you're just I mean you're
making them stronger and more
independent and you're making somebody
that's gonna hate you like forever also
which is what happened well they have
the fortitude and the discipline and and
The Willpower to get out of any any
restrictions you put on them yeah you
know and they and then they're able to
to think their way through
[ __ ] mental traps that you put on
them so they become real Wily you know
they're like oh no no you can't tell me
to do that because the reason why you're
telling the reason why you're teaching
me this is to restrict me and so that
you know what I mean they can get out of
ideologies because they understand it
but Nietzsche was much better at
describing it than I've just described
he it took him a couple paragraphs to
talk about it it was real poetic at
least the English translation
Athena said I only want to be isolated
by my own hands not anyone else's yeah
that's the thing I kind of feel like
one of the things about why a lot of
people like uh that have all this money
but are still miserable like that is
because I think happiness doesn't
necessarily come from money happiness
comes from the amount of control you
feel like you have over your life
um I mean obviously if you have a lot of
money then you have a lot more control
than somebody that's broke but
by the same token if you are in the
royal family like yeah you have a lot of
money but you also have all of these
strictures and rules and [ __ ] like that
that you have to follow and you're so
you feel like your life isn't really
your own so you know what I mean so they
feel like they don't have a lot of
control over their own lives because
they really don't you know but probably
less so nowadays because they can mostly
do what they want but
you know I kind of feel like back in
this time I didn't have to keep up
appearances like they do now
they don't have to keep up appearances
today like that's what I'm saying like
nowadays yeah they still do but it's
like it's not the same as it was they're
just people yeah it's like back then
they were held to like a much higher
standard yeah back then their
interpretation of Christianity was is
that they were drooling by divine right
so their births their births were
actually kind of divine births like
Jesus no sex was involved even some
that's what peasants might may have
believed at certain periods but I don't
think everybody else believed that [ __ ]
but uh a lot of that stuff about in the
American
um Declaration of Independence uh it
doesn't really [ __ ] translate to to
today it starts off a certain certain
part of the uh all men having been
created equal
it's not really what they were talking
about is that all men are not of divine
birth is what they're talking about then
and which was a huge insult to the uh
to the uh to the royal class back in
England in the 1700s because that's
directly saying your parents were
[ __ ] yeah yeah they didn't like that
they didn't like that because they would
evidently deny this I can't understand
but they still do that in North Korea
today Kim Jong-un evidently doesn't [ __ ]
he eats but he doesn't [ __ ] I mean he
must be very constipated
after all this time yeah so you know
it's dynasties
dynasties and monarchies when religion
gets mixed into them always they they
believe in a hokey [ __ ] you know
pharaohs and [ __ ] even the Roman
emperors when they started claiming that
they were divine they would [ __ ] make
some stupid claims you know that they
could talk directly to Jupiter and [ __ ]
like that you know
I kind of I don't know there's a certain
type of person that always likes to have
um something that's somebody's like a
human but is like better than a human
yeah like to look up to like in the case
of like a lot of Western European
monarchies the it was divine birth
Divine rule by divine right yeah that
kind of [ __ ] so they're saying they were
born the same way Jesus was
basically yeah essentially so God came
in and to the mama and and they used
that because
in the Old Testament it basically kind
of says that and it probably reinforces
it back in the New Testament I'd have to
really do the research and I'd probably
talk to Dr Price it says
God has given you these Kings as your
rightful ruler
so in other words to go against the king
is to go against God
always
that that's the that's the natural order
of life
and uh you know that she wouldn't fly
today but that flies back that flew back
then if you had a king that's because
God willed it God LED allowed that King
to be in charge bad or good didn't
matter
if you had a bad king that's because God
willed it so you just couldn't go
against a monarch
and Victoria is still you know as much
as she had like some cool views about
some stuff but she's still like kind of
upheld that kind of thing
um she basically she didn't really get
democracy you know what I mean yeah this
is all totally antithetical to the
American way or at least the original
American way it's back now they've just
replaced it with experts and [ __ ]
oligarchs and [ __ ] scientists and
[ __ ] that's the new rule ruling it's the
new ruling monarchs it just veiled it
and the monarchs are still in there
Royal British royal families are in
charge of the United States certain
aspects of it you know that they got
money you know Money Rules the [ __ ] now
which is that's part of the problem you
know because
the union was designed by its
Constitution to be a classless society
where everybody had equal access to the
law that ain't happening no if you've
got a [ __ ] ton of money you will never
see the inside of a courtroom never
and that was never intended
well it's it's a nice ideal but in
practice it doesn't really it doesn't
really work out that way not until
revolutions happen and they eventually
always happen it's in one way or another
but yeah but I'm saying like I said even
though Victoria I don't even think that
she was ahead of her time she wasn't I
think she was very of her time but she
was actually maybe a little bit behind
the times because like I said the
Industrial Revolution was happening
there were a lot of like cultural
upheavals like you know movements more
toward democracy and she just didn't
want any part of that or she didn't
really like uh she didn't really get it
she still held on to that old school
um you know divine right type of thing I
don't think she was particularly
religious she didn't strike me as
particularly religious but she did think
that you know we're we're
um you know ruling over you because
we're supposed to and that's kind of
like our that that's what we're supposed
to do you know yeah
and I also don't want I don't want
people to think that I'm anti-roy list I
actually think that this kind of stuff
is actually part of the British makeup
that should be this way
um but when you look at at history
ruling classes and monarchs and
dynasties got changed out over time new
ones could appear and form you can get
rid of the old ones
so anything's possible but
the England is is a monarchy is I don't
even think it's constitutional monarchy
is it yeah it is it is constitutional
yeah okay
the monarchy doesn't really have any
power yeah and well Victoria yeah kind
of this was kind of like the first I
mean her Reign actually like ushered
that in where they became more of like a
ceremonial like they could kind of say
hey I don't like that but you know the
Parliament and everything were like we
don't give a [ __ ] you know they could
just kind of do it that's that's just in
public really if you ask me they're the
monarchies in England is the American
equivalent to be would be in oligarchs
they're oligarchs basically because they
still have access to a [ __ ] ton of money
a lot of them and they have a lot of
social power so they can link up with
oligarchs and get certain things done
so they're still powerful you know
they're powerful players over there
don't don't doubt that not one bit
and they're powerful here they got a lot
of money
this is like the church the Catholic
Church
they got a [ __ ] ton of [ __ ] power
they got a lot of [ __ ] uh real estate
and they have their own bank that's very
easy to launder money through you got
Intel agencies have been laundering
money through that Vatican bank for
[ __ ] about a century uh not that 70
years
so they're important too but you know
it's not discussed it's not discussed if
you got a bunch of money you need a
launder your you got black funding
and you're a federal agency in the
United States you can just donate to the
church and they got their own bank and
they can [ __ ] hit and they can
launder money for you that's what they
do
Zach says knowing how Victoria was
raised and how she was later in life I
get the vibe dealing with her was like
dealing with someone with bipolar yeah I
mean she didn't seem like crazy
necessarily but I mean she had a lot of
tragedy in her life she had kind of like
a [ __ ] up like a weird childhood she
seemed like mostly normal but she was
kind of
um very emotional and kind of stubborn
but
most people that met her thought she was
like you know very intelligent and [ __ ]
like that but I don't know she was like
I said she seemed like an interesting uh
person so okay
1836 Victoria had a maternal uncle named
Leopold and he'd been king of the
belgians king of the belgians uh for a
while now he wanted to marry her off to
Prince Albert who I believe was his
nephew yeah because I guess it was his
brother Ernest the first Duke who was
like a Duke and that was like his son so
Albert was actually Victoria's first
cousin which like I said that was [ __ ]
that they did back then keeping it all
in the family uh you know there you go
got a wig and Michael Caine
talking about the royal family they're
going to get British on me
you're going to talk about it yeah
[Laughter]
now you don't look as much like Michael
King because you have the were you
[ __ ] him yeah she was probably yeah
but
so yeah so he's like basically
you know you're in the royal family you
don't really get a choice uh as to who
you marry
so basically uh Leopold the uncle was
like hey why don't you marry my nephew
Albert so Leopold kind of arranged for
Victoria's mom to kind of have all these
relatives over in 1836 and they were
going to introduce the two of them now
interestingly uh Victoria and Albert hit
it off like Victoria was only 17 at the
time because normally like I said they
just married people off for you know
strategic purposes uh to unite families
or to prevent Wars and [ __ ] like that
but and that was probably the case in
this when they set this up too but
actually the two of them did really seem
to like each other and they really did
seem to uh hit it off very famously
um now interestingly William who was I
guess was king at the time yeah because
she hadn't been coronated yet
he did not want uh Victoria and Albert
to marry his pick was this other guy who
was like Prince Alexander of the
Netherlands who was actually one of the
sons of the prince of Orange
now Victoria met Albert she knew what
all of this stuff was going on like I
said I think she was about 17 at this
point and she's like yeah I know that I
have to get married off to somebody or
something like that but when she met
Albert
um she like really dug him and she wrote
it's so cute because she like wrote in
her journal and you could tell she was a
17 year old girl because she writes uh
that Albert is extremely handsome his
hair is about the same color as mine his
eyes are large and blue he has a
beautiful nose
she didn't say a nice ass that would be
right that would have been really funny
he got a tight ass
because you know she was probably
thinking it she just didn't write it
down she's probably afraid I was talking
about that [ __ ] with [ __ ] Sophie and
I even mentioned on the show
because [ __ ] she brought that [ __ ] up
70 of these women are into this [ __ ]
booty magic with these boys I can't
understand it trying to put something up
in a man's booty
once they got these weird fixations
about putting stuff on people of dudes
butts yeah yeah she got on that subject
I was like what talking about I ain't
gonna spill her business
[Laughter]
thank you I think you already got that
way
[Laughter]
possibly the Prince Albert uh dick
piercing was named after Albert himself
supposedly because he had one to keep
his supposedly large one in place yeah
what'd he do like hook it up in his
taint or something yeah is that what
that's what I heard too but I don't know
if that's true I thought it [ __ ]
hooked up into his underwear he had a
[ __ ] yeah button to sewed into his
underwear so he could hold [ __ ] so it
wouldn't like flop around here
they call it dress and write or
something or dress yeah dressed to the
writers where they try to fold their
dicks up so you couldn't see it because
it was supposed to be flat you didn't
want to look like you had a big dick
man you're British all right so whatever
well I guess they thought it was like
uncouth it's like tacky is going right
yeah well it is kind of tacky I mean
it's still kind of tacky nowadays no let
that [ __ ] [ __ ] up
no that's why that's why dudes don't
walk around and like I'm gonna go ahead
I'm gonna go ahead and [ __ ] side with
the leather daddy scene and those dudes
with the art they draw some [ __ ] dude
like that and it's just wrapped all the
way around like a damn [ __ ] huge ass
beer can't go around his [ __ ] leg and
[ __ ] that's much better than not having
like if I had if there's somebody gave
me a choice would you rather be born
this dude here or this one I said yeah
give me that one with that [ __ ] wrapping
around
rather be that guy right there I'll just
hang it over myself
[Laughter]
like the sausages yeah
that's right hanging in a loop like that
you can humble brag about Matt can't
stand this [ __ ]
you humble brag have to like take it out
put it in your pocket dick is too
[ __ ] big I can't stand that [ __ ] not
terrible when you dick
is over on the side and [ __ ] look like
an apple like a big old Apple Bowl yeah
I can't stand unreasonable
like a [ __ ] fist on the end of there
man that's too big none of these women
will [ __ ] with me
I can't get a date set in my life
they're all too little they're all too
small these women
you know that's you know that's how that
shit's going down that's how you're
gonna humble brag about it yeah
well some girls do that too oh yeah oh
my God I'm so skinny my tits are so big
I can't stand it I can't do anything
with these yeah
although I feel that I can't find a bra
they're too big I feel those are too
small well yeah but when your tits are
big it is kind of like kind of a pain in
the ass though yeah but when you've paid
for them that's true but I'm just saying
it is kind of a good right like if
they're naturally big and you didn't ask
for that [ __ ] then yeah no they got that
girls with [ __ ] 3 600 [ __ ] 38 3600
CC implants going for I can't stand it
they don't make bras big enough for me
you know
yeah I know your life yeah yeah yeah
yeah
Zach said uh hey Victoria did write
about how amazing the sex with Albert
was in a roundabout way yeah I mean she
wrote about a lot of stuff uh like that
so
yeah she her and Albert were really
really into each other to be honest they
were both like she thought that he was
super super hot
um he was that he looked like I mean
from the paintings I'm sure like the
paintings look better than real life but
um you know he looked like a pretty
handsome dude like when he was young
like I said they were kids when they met
I don't know how much older he was than
her I don't think he was that much older
she was 17 when they first met but um
yeah she called him like delightful said
he had fine teeth like I said she didn't
say a nice ass but maybe she was
thinking that
um I hope she was
uh but the other guy the one that the
king wanted her to marry Alexander uh
all she said about him was very plain
yeah and I said about it yeah who said
that about her no nobody said that about
her she said that about the other guy
that the king wanted her diary right
yeah she went into it no she wasn't into
it and I've seen a painting of that guy
and he's like okay looking too so I
don't know like I said painting is hard
to tell because I'm sure they make you
look better they make you look better
than you actually damn filters yeah
that's like the Instagram filter of the
19th century yeah well you can't got a
little bit more and you got a [ __ ]
fantastic name oh and I'll make it look
great don't worry yeah it's like can you
like have me like not have this like
acne and double chance and [ __ ] like
that yeah can you look good yeah
give me some like nicer hair yeah make
my teeth nice you know
uh but yeah so Victoria was so Smitten
by Albert that she actually wrote to
Leopold her uncle who was had set the
whole thing up and wrote him a letter
like you pretty much gushing about
you're so awesome for uh setting us up
um she says about Albert he possesses
every quality that could be desired to
render me perfectly happy he's so
sensible so kind and so good and so
amiable too he has besides the most
pleasing and delightful exterior and
appearance that you can possibly see
like I said she thought he was hot now
uh so she's only 17 at this point so
she's kind of like well she thought she
was too young to get married and she's
like she didn't want to rush into it
either so they didn't really do like the
whole formal engagement thing but
they're like okay well that's probably
gonna happen at that point in the future
so Victoria turns 18 uh in May of 1837.
oh look pokey's on the show Pookie on
the show Pookie's on the show she's like
yep I'm just putting up with it putting
up with it
she just puts up with it yeah she's like
[ __ ] I gotta go we're hanging out
next to me you don't want to come up on
the lap she's looking at me going why
did you pick me up yeah she think I
don't like it yeah don't pick me up I
was just sitting here on the floor on
the floor Katie she's not really a lap
kid like she'll come to you and like
give you a headbutt or like sit up on my
desk or something like that but it's
like if you pick her up she's like
David says if I'm using Chia shampoo
this is my Michael Kane wig I had to get
British for this show all right yeah
that's the only he didn't want to do the
Mozart wig well Mozart wasn't pretty
sure
German or Austrian or something he's
Austrian or something I thought he was
wasn't he Austrian Tom or German
I can't remember he was some kind of
German I read he's some kind of jerk
he's one of those kinds of Germans
there's lots of different kinds of the
same uh Danny Rowling said isn't it
custom for the king to deflower his
daughters I don't probably In some
cultures I'm sure I don't buy it
I don't buy it either that would be a
little bit weird well the thing about it
is that you even in royal families where
incest is kind of common well it's not
even incest it's kind of more like just
cousins which like I said is still weird
but it's not that weird I mean they're
related but they're not as related as
like brothers and sisters now ancient
Egypt I think they were doing brothers
and sisters too and ancient that's okay
that's weird
and I've and from an evolutionary
standpoint too like most people well the
thing about it okay from what I read and
please correct me if I'm wrong
but brothers and sisters that are
genetically related as well as
stepbrothers and stepsisters that were
raised together they are grossed out by
the thought of having sex with one
another right and that's kind of like an
evolutionary thing apparently that makes
sure it doesn't happen to make sure that
it doesn't happen because usually people
that you are raised with are genetically
related to you and that's not a good
idea because of you know genetic
abnormalities however brothers and
sisters who
um were like separated at Birth like
raised apart and then meet later on in
life they tend to like really really dig
each other and sometimes get and they're
not really sure like exactly why that is
so it's not necessarily so much a
genetic thing as like a raised together
type of thing well if you looked at it
that's what I heard if you look like
king Ramses back in the uh the Egyptian
Empire phase
he was uh he evidently had thousands of
children okay he had hundreds of wives
and thousands of children you know or
maybe maybe even tens of thousands of
children but he was stalking
his government
with these children so he had his sons
in all these positions yeah
but evidently a lot of these
wives and concubines
that he had access to he had access to
hundreds and hundreds of women were also
like daughters
but I don't think he knew those
daughters you know I mean I don't think
they were raised together because there
was a he has such a large breeding pool
of [ __ ] people out there that they
were Ramses was having sex with
but eventually some of his Brides were
daughters
weird that is pretty but
like I said he probably didn't meet him
until they're 18 or 19 and I missed just
like another stranger but they were
trying to it all had to do with
government loyalty more than anything
else you're not going to betray the king
if you're directly related to him and
that's really what they were doing it
wasn't any some kind it wasn't really
Kink yeah it wasn't like freaky in that
way it was just like it was almost like
a pragmatic yeah they didn't want any
betrayals so you're like well I can't
[ __ ]
if I can't foam in an uprising against a
king he's my dad you know I'm in charge
he put me in charge of his army you know
that was the kids kill their dads all
the time yeah but they were just it's a
lot less it's a lot less like I know
it's a lot less likely
and they evidently they raised them
separately you know they were almost
kind of like a military type situation
so what you're talking about really you
know in terms of Hollywood you know
you're talking about [ __ ] Meng the
merciless on [ __ ] planet [ __ ] with
his [ __ ] daughter princess aura
which
my take of the movie is that he was
hitting our and that was his daughter
yeah didn't she didn't you get that take
from that yeah
coming on to him you know coming on to
Daddy and [ __ ] like that and asking for
[ __ ] other men and you know asking
for a [ __ ] fight give me flash please
oh your tastes are far too dangerous you
know but evidently some [ __ ] was going
on there that they were all perverts and
Flash Gordon that's why I [ __ ] love
that movie man because I was watching
this book is a kiki
and they were kinky in the original
[ __ ] Source material go back and
watch old Flash Gordon drugs and sex and
[ __ ]
I gotta tell you with that Michael Kane
wig and the beard in the mustache you
kind of look like a 70s porn star now
yeah okay
I'm done with this you should
you should see it's too [ __ ] hot
hey I wear a wig all night
you know and I have hair underneath
that's not I'm not even bald I could
shave
no I can't I wouldn't look good with a
bald head what are you talking about
you'd wear a wig well I can't wear a
wigs is she did she throw it
yeah right
all right so Victoria turns 18 in May of
1837. and it so happened that less than
a month later William IV croaked he was
the king
he was 71 years old
and just like that Victoria became the
queen how she found out they basically
she was sleeping and they woke her up at
like six in the morning
uh and she just like the architecture
Archbishop of Canterbury was there like
all these people came and she just like
comes out of her little dressing gown or
whatever they're like oh by the way your
uncle kicked the bucket or your
grandfather or whoever it was like kick
the bucket and uh you're a queen now
it's six o'clock in the morning and
you're in your jammies still so uh yeah
that's how she found out what I thought
was kind of like funny
so like I said one of the first things
that she did well I think the first
thing that she did was she didn't want
to go by her uh first name anymore
alexandrina and she went by her second
name which was Victoria
um so you know she just didn't want to
use it and uh I think also that she
wanted Conroy like that dude like she's
like yeah I just want to make it uh my
first queenly decree is I don't want to
see that motherfucker's face ever again
so he was still around like because he
worked for her mom more than anything so
he was still around but she was like
yeah I don't want him she it was kind of
like kind of like she filed a
restraining order like he wasn't allowed
to become within like certain distance
ever or something like that it was
something like that
so uh so basically on the day that she
uh that they did the coronation the
prime minister at the time uh who was a
wig his name was Lord Melbourne and he
was actually like really nice to her
like he came out and said
congratulations and it's like oh you're
gonna do so good and all this other kind
of stuff and I think that this was the
first time that she had ever because he
was like her like a dad figure to her
like pretty much because she didn't
really have one because her dad died
when she was uh little
and you know and Conroy had been around
but he just like [ __ ] on her all the
time telling her how stupid she was so
she had never had like a man like a
father figure in her life tell her oh
I'm so proud of you and you're gonna do
a good job you know what I mean so I
think this was like really weird and
like kind of nice like kind of a nice
change so her and the Prime Minister
Lord Melbourne actually became uh close
friends uh Lord Melbourne I guess he was
a he his wife had died so he was a
widower
and so he he kind of like saw her as
like a daughter to him because like I
said she was only like 18. so the two of
them like got really close and he was
also like really important uh because he
was a political advisor I mean like I
said she didn't have a lot of political
experience she was just a kid really and
so he helped her out a lot uh in that
regard
um and apparently they hung out a lot
too like doing puzzles and [ __ ] she said
that he was real funny and like he made
her laugh like he had a really good
sense of humor like they had to act all
serious in public and [ __ ] like that but
the thing about Queen Victoria one of
the things that I think
was interesting to me about her was she
liked people that were
regular people like she liked people
that were like honest and funny and
would like talk to her like she was a
normal person you know what I mean
because I guess she didn't really have
too much of that in her life she didn't
really like it seemed like she didn't
really like all of the ceremonial kind
of [ __ ] where you had to look a certain
way and be a certain way and you know
the public perception I think she didn't
really like that so like when she met
somebody that was just like cool or like
you know was a drunk and like made jokes
with her and like you know busted her
chops and stuff like that I think she
liked that because it was somebody
treating her like a regular person which
she'd never really had happen before
so I think that that was kind of her and
Lord Melbourne like they would kind of
like hang out how old was she at this
point she's 18. she was 18. when
Melbourne's wet 40s um I don't know how
old he was he was much older he was much
older like I said she he was like her
dad you know what I mean like she saw
him as a dad because she didn't have a
dad you know her dad had died when she
was a baby so and all she had was Conroy
and he was a douche so there was that so
yeah so but she asked him for advice all
the time and he was actually you know
really good at like uh you know helping
her out with
uh you know being Queen because she
didn't really know how to do it you know
uh so basically the thing so she gets uh
the coronation was in uh June of 1838
about 400 000 people came to London to
see it and she was actually the first
Sovereign to uh start living in
Buckingham Palace uh I believe the
construction had only recently just been
completed uh so she was the first one to
move in there first one to live in there
now she actually got I don't know if
this is in back in those days money or
nowadays money but her civil allowance
and this wasn't the only money she got
because she also got money from like
other like uh from Lancaster and
Cornwall and stuff but her civil
allowance was 385 pounds per year
and I think that's back then money which
that's a lot of [ __ ] money really
that's a lot of [ __ ] money if that's
I mean that's a lot of money now but if
that was like back then 900 pounds no
385
000 pounds 385 000 pounds per year and I
think that's in Victorian era money
that's a [ __ ] ton of money tens of
millions every year I mean but that
makes sense though because there was a
lot of [ __ ] that they maintained yeah
one of the first things she did though
like when she first got her thing so she
wasn't like completely crazy like her
dad had run up a bunch of debts and she
paid them all off right like with her
first so I was like yeah well okay at
least she was like kind of prudent in
that way
um now interestingly at the start of her
Reign for like the first year
um she was actually really really
popular which doesn't surprise me
because she was like the like cute
little 18 year old girl uh you know
coming in there little bitty thing like
I said
but uh about a year after she got
crowned
there was some kind of like uh her
popularity took a hit because there was
some Palace Intrigue okay
what ended up happening was one of her
mother's ladies in Waiting whose name
was Lady Flora Hastings
she got this abdominal growth
and it looked like she was pregnant so
the rumors started going around the
[ __ ] Conroy the douche had knocked
her up and this was an out of wedlock
pregnancy which is a big [ __ ] deal
right
now Victoria because she [ __ ] hated
Conroy and did like throughout her
entire life and she also hated lady
Flora Hastings because lady Flora had
been in on that whole like [ __ ] when
they died on a thing well no we'll had
been in on that whole thing when she was
being brought up like Hey we're she's
not allowed to like see any other kids
or anything with the Kensington method
or whatever they called it she was in on
that so she hated that [ __ ] too so
she's basically like oh yeah I believe
that [ __ ] um you know [ __ ] that [ __ ]
um so basically Kensington system that's
what it was called
now um so she kind of was out in the
media saying yeah that's totally true
now lady Flora At first she wouldn't
like go to the doctor to like prove
she's like I'm not pregnant it's like
but she wouldn't go to the doctor to
like prove it but then she eventually
did and they did an examination and they
found out that she was still a virgin
yeah which is not possible so yeah so
she wasn't pregnant and then like to add
icing to the to the [ __ ] cake here uh
not only that but they found out that
the abdominal growth was actually a
liver tumor that ended up killing her
like not that long afterward
so obviously this whole debacle uh
really kind of like uh Victoria kind of
because she had come out and said like
[ __ ] those people yeah I believe that
[ __ ] and then she'd kind of like spread
the rumor as well and said that she
believed it and uh so after that like
Conroy and like the whole Hastings
family like the woman's family and also
the Tories who were in opposition to her
uh they actually had this whole big
campaign in the press against her for
spreading like false rumors about her
and like yeah then she [ __ ] died
don't you feel bad so you know her
popularity like took a big hit because
of that
so she would like go out and do public
appearances and stuff and everybody
would like [ __ ] hiss at her and [ __ ]
because of the stuff that she did yeah
that was a big thing in the Victorian
area
which I'd be like okay
okay I don't understand why that was
supposed to made me mad but whatever
um Lord Conroy too meanwhile uh was
still trying to pull some [ __ ] he
actually approached Lord Melbourne the
prime minister at the time and he said
oh hey Victoria said that you were gonna
give me a pension of three thousand
pounds a year and plus you're gonna give
me some land and a title and like a seed
in court and [ __ ] like that and
Melbourne said what read what Zach said
he he he he did the the uh how much her
yearly yeah in 1837 is worth 48 billion
48 million no billion is it no because
that's 48 million 877
693.47 or Pence yeah I don't have my
glasses on I thought it was 48 billion
okay I did two for a second but then
like I'm counting the number yeah 48
million yeah it's basically 50 million
48 million is that all 40 48 million a
year she got 49 million a year Jesus
Christ
you can maintain I take that you could
yeah me too I take that you could
maintain the [ __ ] out of a lifestyle
only need one mansion that's it
just the one just one then I fly around
go to hotels
see that's what I would do go down to
[ __ ] Dubai and [ __ ] me and Jenny
Dubai
hanging out Dubai drinking all that
[ __ ] high-class skull girls Jenny
tearing them up
me back there with the camera
sounds good yeah
putting that [ __ ] off on only fans
making more money
finally do our [ __ ] family style
[ __ ] family style porn yeah
it's like the KFC family
I was thinking of Olive Garden but same
concept
it's family style yeah
Danny Rowling said were there ever any
assassination attempts on Queen Victoria
uh several I believe there were seven or
eight assassination attempts against her
we'll get into that yeah there was a
bunch
um they were some of them were kind of
serious but none of them uh even got
close to succeeding like she wasn't even
like wounded in any of them really
um yeah Zach said and that's worth 54
million dollars now
to 54 million dollars a year I think I
could live on that maybe
I could probably live on that that's
enough money a year to worry me you can
only give me you can give me the 50
million once and I I'd like okay that's
it I'm good
yeah I don't I don't think I need it
every year every year that I mean I
could live the rest I could live several
lifetimes on 50 million dollars 50
million a year that might actually scare
me you know what I mean like I'd see
that [ __ ] [ __ ] piling up in there
I'm getting really nervous I'm gonna get
in trouble
private jets and [ __ ] that's what I
needed it's like I can't really say
because I've never had anything like
anything approaching that amount of
money
but maybe it just gets to a point where
you're just like so rich that you're
just kind of like you just buy [ __ ] all
the time that you're not even gonna use
because I don't know I just kind of feel
like like why the [ __ ] would you need a
lot of that here's something I found out
recently when you have that kind of
money and you own those private jets you
don't ever go through customs you don't
even need those people oh yeah I know
those people don't even have passports
yeah right they can just fly to anywhere
and they land so I get that like they
land in these makes your life easier
they land on these little private
airports at their friends places and
[ __ ] and little airfields and they don't
they're Above the Law like I said before
they're Above the Law and governments
that's all for us
but that's how it is the little people
it's because we put out with it
the Athena said I can't get my mind
around that amount I can't either I
can't imagine what it would be like to
just like not worry about money because
that's all I've done you could give me a
million I could live on that I could too
easily well [ __ ] I've lived on way less
my whole entire life I just paid this
house off
yeah and you still have a bunch of what
was left over I could I could scrimp on
that and then my [ __ ] pension I'd
live good yeah on that like I said I'm
not a real I don't I need a bunch of
[ __ ] I don't need a bunch of [ __ ] I've
gone past the point in my life where
it's like I that I need to impress other
people and also like there's a bunch of
stuff that I was like why would I even
spend money on that because I wouldn't
use it you know what I mean if I had
that much money my biggest fear was
would be to lose it
you know what I'm talking about it would
almost be like a burden I think you
could get real used to that and then
you'd probably start worrying about
losing that money well yeah because if
you've been poor your whole life it
sucks but I think there might be
something a little bit more
existentially worse about being poor get
having a whole bunch of money and then
like getting used to that and then
losing it all right and then you're poor
again but you now with the knowledge of
what it was like like not like having a
bunch of money yeah
so I can see how that would [ __ ] you up
big time yeah but you can see like why
it happens to a lot of like lottery
winners and stuff like that like people
that were always poor and they win a
[ __ ] ton of money like they usually end
up
not always but a lot of them do kind of
end up in a bad place they either end up
like losing all the money or they end up
like really really miserable yeah and
that's why because they're not used to
it like they either blow it because
they're not used to having that kind of
money or
you know and then after they lose it
again they're just kind of like oh my
God like it's even worse than it was
before because before at least my life
sucked but I was used to it being sucky
and now it's already better and yeah you
didn't know any better right my dad
doesn't know anybody as far as my dad's
concerned it's still it's still it's
still 1990 as far as my dad's concerned
oh but it's 1990 from the Viewpoint of
[ __ ]
1980 you know okay yeah you have to
understand the South
but uh no it's just [ __ ] it's funny
yeah
all right talks more about the lottery
oh yeah
okay
I talked to my dad a couple days ago I
said I'm gonna come down there and see
you over the next couple months I'm
gonna I I got some [ __ ] I got to do and
all yeah if I'm still here
he's convinced he's dying
so
I'm uh asking him you know he's got to
do chemo he doesn't know if he really
wants to do it
he's down to 130 pounds
[ __ ]
so he doesn't have much longer to go but
I said look man if they're telling you
to do the [ __ ] chemo just do the
chemo it might buy you some more time
he's getting super depressed you know
but I think the last time I talked to
him I bucked him up some you know uh
is just [ __ ] rough you know [ __ ]
we have a lot of a lot of friends here
on the Channel that I talk to off the
channel That their dads died you know if
I can uh you know I [ __ ] went through
it with [ __ ] Khan uh down in Mexico
when his dad died you know and I was
like yeah my dad's doing doing bad too
you know and you guys some of you guys
have been with me
long enough to back when I had to go
back to Mississippi and for his [ __ ]
quadruple bypass and I didn't think he
was going to make it there
so I'm amazed that he's lasted as long
as he has even though he's not that old
he's just in real bad shape
a lot of it had to do with [ __ ]
diabetes which is a bullet that I dodged
but if you ever got diabetes
and I think a lot of it had to do with
the diet he was raised with [ __ ]
hardcore [ __ ] old school Southern
diet
a diabetes [ __ ] ravaged him he didn't
have a [ __ ] tooth in his head
[ __ ]
cancer got him
but uh I have to do something
I don't want to fly down there though I
[ __ ] I don't want to fly I want to
ride down there on my bike I gotta get
some saddle bags yeah it's not far it's
not that far it's only eight hours
I could ride that easy eight to ten
hours
and I want when I get there I want to
have my own vehicle I want to go through
all this
going through these [ __ ] airports and
then renting a car and paying all that
money when [ __ ] I could just [ __ ]
ride down there on my [ __ ] bill
and then having my bike when I got there
but when he goes I gotta go back to that
house
I'll probably get his truck
all the other [ __ ] that he has he's got
a [ __ ] ton of guns he's got a [ __ ]
gun safe [ __ ] super high-tech gun
safe that has cameras in it with [ __ ]
a hard drive that records who stands in
front of the damn [ __ ] thing it
starts recording your face
um he's got a lot of good [ __ ]
which I'd have to [ __ ] pack that
truck up and bring it here
but he's also got a lot of junk
and I don't I don't want that house even
though I'm not really I'm really not
next in line for that house his sister
is
she doesn't want it she's only a little
bit younger than him but
it would go to his sister and then it'd
probably end up one of my cousins
well I mean that's the thing it's but
it's not worth anything that's what I
mean it seems like oh neat uh like I got
left a house but it just seems like it
probably it's way out of middle of
nowhere more troubling yeah because even
if somebody even if it got left to you
you'd have to like just have it cleaned
out you'd have to sell it you'd have to
like and it just it seemed like it would
be too much yeah you would think that I
would be next in line but it's not
he inherited he inherited that from his
mom
so it went from his mom to his sister
not to him and his son so
that's just the the order of secession
so it would go if he dies it goes to his
sister and then his sister will die
right after that it'll go to probably my
cousin Scott
but the thing is the house is only it's
not worth anything it's a location you
know yeah Danny Rowling said Airbnb but
it's like where it is no there's nothing
there nobody would stay there it's like
as an Airbnb no it's Heidelberg
Mississippi out in the middle of nowhere
Heidelberg Mississippi population 600
500 maybe
there's a little German town and my dad
is the last white guy uh he's got real
good neighbors that take care of him
Clarice and his and his and her husband
who's a local National Guard [ __ ]
platoon Sergeant I've talked to him
online and I met Clarice she came to see
him in the hospital
and uh but he's the last white guy then
and there they take care of him he's uh
the Deep South is not what Outsiders
think it is
um especially in some of these towns you
know I mean black people and white
people got along real well
they watched out for each other because
it's country it's not
they all know each other
and uh it's just part of Southern
Culture
and they uh
the check on them every day feed him
give him turkey necks
and uh he watches their children he'd
take clarice's son out fishing with him
all the time you know when he was a
little little boy
and he raised two other black sons
really [ __ ] went out since I was gone
and they were the neighbors kids
uh did he take them hunting and fishing
and they grew up and joined the army
[ __ ] gone one of them went to jail
um but it's just it's just how it is you
know
and um
they just
watched him before he checks out
but that's the cycle of life that's the
way it is with a force you know
yeah
Mark says these monarchs needed that
kind of money to compete in the moderate
game though if you could outspend your
enemy you win yeah that's true I mean it
just seems like so much [ __ ] money
though Zach said if if I ever won the
lottery I put half of it away for
whatever reason and use the other half
to self-finance a movie yeah see like
something like that would be kind of
cool I would definitely save half of it
just like right off the Jump just in
case well I was like sticking in an
account that I couldn't get to so I'd
always like have it there but then the
rest of it I might like do some fun
shape with
but you know it's never gonna happen so
I don't know why I could dream about it
but uh yeah so anyway
what were you talking about okay so we
were talking about Conroy being a douche
and uh finagling uh Melbourne who was
then the Prime Minister and to give him
three thousand pounds a year and some
land and [ __ ] like that saying hey
Victoria said it was okay and he's like
oh okay and then she's like [ __ ]
I didn't say that that was okay so she
like was like get the [ __ ] out of my
face again
1839 uh Melbourne
Lord Melbourne actually resigned after
the Tories and the radicals uh Victoria
didn't like either one of those groups
they actually voted against a bill to
they were going to suspend Jamaica's
Constitution
over uh the bill was actually removing
power from the plantation owners because
they were trying to get rid of slavery
and the plantation owners were not
having it so they were trying to like do
that kind of thing
so Melbourne quit over that and Victoria
was like really really upset like she
wrote about it in her journals like I
said she's only you know she wasn't very
old at this point like only in like in
her 20s or something so she wrote about
it in her journals like it was the end
of the [ __ ] world like she was very
very drama queen about it
uh because that was like her buddy you
know what I mean and she didn't know it
was gonna happen now that he wasn't
prime minister
so she actually got uh a guy who was a
Tory whose name was Robert peel and he
uh became the next prime minister
now here was another kind of scan I
don't know if it was necessarily a
scandal but another kind of like a big
debacle that happened at the time so
around in this era I guess like the
Prime Minister would come in the new
prime minister would come in and they
would actually appoint members of the
royal household like you know people
that were friends of his like his
political allies like in the same party
as him and like the wives of some of the
other ministers and things like that
they would um kind of put them in
positions uh in the Royal household you
know what I mean like as ladies in
Waiting or whatever the [ __ ] so there
was that
so
um basically when he came in
Victoria's ladies of the bed chamber
which I'm not quite sure what that
entails but it doesn't sound fun it
sounds like it sounds like the the
it sounds like maid it sounds like
you're gonna be in there like you know
getting getting the queen into her
corset and like emptying her bedpan and
[ __ ] like that that's what it sounds
like to me I don't know if that's what
it is but that's what it sounds like
now when Robert peel came in though
um most of the ladies of the bed chamber
were the wives of wigs because that's
the party that um that Melbourne had
been part of
so when peel comes in he just expected
as was the custom that
um yeah you're gonna be getting rid of
all of your bed chamber ladies and
replacing them with the wives of people
from the Tory party because that's just
what we do it's a different party now
and we're all working together
um however Victoria had actually made
very good friends with her bed chamber
ladies and she put her foot down and she
was like no I'm not doing that these are
my friends and like I said I kind of
feel like because of the way she grew up
I feel like when she
made a friend
um you know and or somebody that she
could really relate to and talk to like
she hung out of that person for dear
life and was like really really loyal to
them so I kind of feel like she really
did like these ladies and hung out with
them and they were her close confidants
and stuff so she really balked at the
idea of you know getting rid of all of
them and having like a bunch of strange
ass [ __ ] like coming in there
doing whatever ladies of the bed chamber
do so she was like no we're not doing
that
so uh because of this uh this actually
became known for real as the bed chamber
crisis it was a bed chamber crisis
because she was like no I don't want
these random ass ladies in here
um so and Melbourne too who like I said
was not had resigned like uh being prime
minister he actually advised her as like
yeah tell that [ __ ] like don't
don't tell him like don't get rid of
your friends [ __ ] like that
um this was such a big deal that peel
actually was like well I can't [ __ ]
work with this and he quit like as prime
minister he was like [ __ ] this [ __ ] and
like was out of there just over that
they missed it over what it's called the
bed chamber crisis yeah okay so I'm
gonna have to repeat it for Tom because
he wasn't here I don't worry about it
I mean yeah no it's it's interesting
it's interesting actually I'll just I'll
give you the I'll give you the The
Cliffs notes version all right so
basically uh Melbourne who is a wig he
resigned they bring in a new uh prime
minister who was a Tory now what they
had been doing up to this point was that
the Prime Minister would basically like
put members of his own party or their
wives or something like that like in
positions in the Royal household
so uh Victoria's ladies at the bed
chamber uh were all wigs and when peel
came in he's like oh well you're going
to be firing all those ladies and
bringing in you know Tori ladies because
that's kind of what we do and she and
she said no I'm not doing that because
these are all my friends and peel was
like [ __ ] this [ __ ] I'm quitting yeah
okay so then they called it like the bed
chamber crisis which I thought they had
very funny
I mean like I said they care they were
her friends well that was just how it
was done and I guess because it's like
well that's the party in power because
that's the prime minister's party and so
they expected to have all of these other
party friendly people like in the Royal
House like working in there you know
what I mean so they would all like work
together whatever but Victoria was at
all influencer thinking well and like I
said Victoria I don't even think she did
it for any particular political reason
it was just that she liked these ladies
because they'd been her but the other
political parties wanted to get pretty
good influence exactly but she just
didn't like it you know what I mean
because she was loyal to them because
she well those other girls [ __ ] about
that stuff she thought of them as her
friends and she didn't want to [ __ ] them
over I kind of that was the impression
that I got yeah so she stood up for
herself but peel quit uh over that and
actually Melbourne uh got to return to
office for a little while now Victoria I
mean it should be noted didn't really
like peel anyway
um because he basically like treated her
like she was stupid just like Conroy had
and and she was uh she did not like that
one bit
um you know because she'd grown up her
whole life with Conroy telling her how
stupid she was so she didn't like dudes
like that so she didn't like him anyway
she was like I had good riddance
whatever
now uh though Victoria was was Queen now
uh she was still young and she was still
unmarried and so because it was the
social convention at the time she still
had to live with her mom
she did not get along with her mom
because Mom and Conroy was still hanging
out right uh so basically her mom like
she's like okay well fine mom can live
in Buckingham Palace but she gotta move
way the [ __ ] over there on the other
side of the palace so I never have to
see her [ __ ] face yeah so it's like
and her mom would like try and come to
see her and she's like no so she
wouldn't she I mean she really did not
like her mom they kind of reconciled a
little bit later but
I mean she didn't really forget for it
seemed well it was vying for power for
all the yeah I do kind of feel like
there was that too
now
um so basically Victoria goes to
Melbourne the Prime Minister and is like
you know what the [ __ ] is with this
she's like I can't stand like being
around my [ __ ] mom all the time and
until you know if she just has to live
in this house and I don't like it and
Melbourne was like um you know if you
get married then you could avoid this
whole thing and Victoria's like oh yeah
that's right now at this point like I
said she was only in her 20s maybe I
think she was 20 years old around this
time
so she hadn't wanted to like rush into
marriage or anything like that but they
had already kind of sort of not
unofficially like her and Albert were
gonna hook up so she was like okay well
maybe we should Fast Track that so I can
kind of get rid of my mom because I
can't stand having her around
so uh so Albert does another visit in
1839
so
he comes there to visit and he's only
there for five days and Victoria
proposed to him now that sounds weird uh
you know especially considering the uh
you know the the conventions of the time
but it's actually not weird because she
was a monarch and he wasn't so it would
have been inappropriate for him to
propose to her because she outranked him
essentially so she was the one that had
to say hey let's get married and he's
like okay so they did uh so they got
married in uh 1840 like in February
and she basically I mean she wrote in
her diet like I said she's only 20 so
give her a break you know what I mean
but she was like man she was like super
gushing about the day after the wedding
so I'm assuming yeah that it was like
kind of a sex thing and she was uh she
basically writes and this is just so
teenage girl it's so funny she's like I
never never spent such an evening my
dearest dearest dear Albert his
excessive love and affection gave me
feelings of heavenly love and happiness
I never could have hoped to have felt
before yeah she got late
but yeah it just kind of goes on like
that um so yeah the happiest day of my
life all this like everything the Bliss
beyond belief stuff like that so yeah
she got laid for the first time and she
was like super super happy about it but
like I said they really did seem to love
each other so I thought and that was
something that you didn't really see
with a lot of royal family so you know
that was nice for them I guess
now uh so when they got married though
there was kind of like I don't know if
they necessarily meant this I think the
thing about Victoria is that there was a
lot of like stuff political stuff going
on around her I'm not really sure of how
aware of
the repercussions of what she did were I
you know I don't want to like say that
she was clueless but I think that a lot
of other I think she just didn't care as
much about Convention as like some other
people did or care about like oh
politically this expedient was or that
was she was just like well I'm just
gonna do whatever the [ __ ] like not
worry about it I I kind of got that
impression from her I could be totally
wrong but that's kind of how I read it
so the when they got married
um they didn't really invite that many
Tories because like I said she wasn't
really a big fan of them
that's what peel had been and um
basically she came out and said Well
Albert should be just like uh second in
command you know what I mean and the
Tories were like yeah no we're not doing
that we're not like recognizing his
authority as second to yours like and
she got really really mad about it she
called them monsters and said she was
gonna get revenge against them and [ __ ]
like that
about it though was that the longer she
was married to Albert like he was
actually really influential on her
um beliefs and like just the way she was
you know what I mean
um she had been
you know friends with Melbourne for a
long time who was a wig and he was kind
of like her father figure but the longer
she was married to Albert like the less
influence that Melbourne had on her so I
guess like Albert kind of like took over
that role you know what I'm saying
um so she kind of like got less
enthusiastic about the wigs whereas
before she'd been all about it because
Melbourne that was like her best friend
you know what I mean but Albert was
definitely like the dominant uh figure
in her life as time went on and it got
to a point too where
some of the like something that I saw
like one quote said that she didn't even
put on a gown or a bonnet if he didn't
approve it so it got to a point where
and like some historians have thought
that maybe he was like actually reigning
it like that she was only Queen and name
only like I'm not saying that she didn't
know what was going on I think she did
because she was like really intelligent
but a lot of historians say that maybe
he was running [ __ ]
you know with just like behind her front
or whatever but I don't know if that's
the case but some uh historians have
said that
so um so basically
because that's the thing when they first
got married she was like yeah I don't
want Albert to have anything to do with
governing the country but then like you
know six months later she was
um letting Albert see like all the
updates and dispatches and stuff like
that like all the business and then
um he was able to be he was allowed to
be present like when she was meeting
with all the ministers and everything
like that and then he started getting
all the keys and the thing about it too
was that she started getting pregnant
like because they had nine kids right so
she was pregnant a lot and she hated
being pregnant which you know I get that
she was not a big fan of pregnancy she
was not a big fan of breastfeeding she
was not a big fan of children uh she
thought babies were ugly and gross and
uh so she was and she suffered a lot it
seems like from postpartum depression as
well like so she have a kid and then
like she'd be really bummed out about it
and then like she'd get pregnant again
so it seemed like she was always like
convalescing so Albert kind of had to I
think she just kind of like got worn out
you know what I mean and she was just
like so she just like let Albert run
some [ __ ] because she was like look I'm
fat and I'm hot and I have hemorrhoids
or whatever and she's like I don't want
to [ __ ] deal with this [ __ ] right now
which like I said I get it
um you know what I mean it's she really
really really hated being pregnant uh
she actually
she called it what did she call it she
called it like the shadow side of
marriage child bearing she liked being
married to Albert she wasn't a big fan
of marriage in general but she really
did love him but she man she hated she
loved her kids but man she really did
not like being pregnant or the whole
child birthing thing she just [ __ ]
hated it and was not shy about talking
about it either so I don't know I just
thought that was like really funny
so I mean when she first started out I
kind of feel like she was very gung-ho
like she's like I'm gonna be Queen and
I'm gonna help the country and I'm gonna
run everything but then like as time
went on and she just kept getting
pregnant and kept having kids and stuff
like that and she was just like man I
don't think I can [ __ ] do this
anymore because I'm [ __ ] tired
um and she even got to a point where she
said she didn't think that women were
fit for governing like maybe
from that idea because she just like
brings up a good question what's that
right there you were right there where
is it towards the bottom I wonder if the
king also has the gentleman of the bed
chamber yeah I don't know probably I
mean they had
I would like to look up like when they
say ladies of the bed chamber I was
assuming that that was like your your
Maids like your handmaids that would
like help you get dressed because back
then they had like uh well back then
they had like 40 bajillion layers of
clothing yeah you made out of the bed
chamber is a little skinny uh gay dude
that comes and uh blows you
to help release tension
probably does that [ __ ] it gets that
kneels down you're sitting in a chair
like that you eat through the edge like
that it gets up here and it's all
gentlemanly and everything it's all
gentlemen yes it's not a sexual thing
it's just a uh it's maintenance
it's like getting oil change
something like that I kind of assumed
that I mean I kind of assume that too
because I have a dirty mind but I kind
of assume that like I said they'd come
in and like empty your your chamber pot
and like you know fill your water basin
and like [ __ ] like that because there
was a lot more stuff they didn't have
running water back then they didn't have
like you know so they'd come in and like
fix your hair and like do your [ __ ] like
get you dressed and all that kind of
stuff yeah
I just assumed that that's what it was
yeah so like I said it's essentially
like a maid job yeah I think it's what
it is it's like being an amazing it's
your friends to come in and take care of
you yeah yeah
I can't imagine I can't imagine having
like fun well they're hanging out you
know what I mean doing girl stuff doing
girl stuff I totally imagine it
talking about boys talking about dudes
talking about boys yeah well she grew up
with them so it was going to be like
that and they were talking about dudes
and [ __ ] you know and talking about
the latest issue of Tiger Beat yeah
making sure washing her feet yeah
putting her [ __ ] clothes on well I
hope they are doing her makeup and her
hair and [ __ ] if I could do you know
dude braiding and hair and [ __ ] yeah of
course that's what that was all about
one of the things that always kind of
killed me was like back then man there
was like just so much that they had
especially if you were in that kind of
position where you actually had to look
like you know you had to have all the
full regalia like on all the time
because you were like a public eye it's
like how [ __ ] long did it take to get
rid I mean even nowadays with all of our
modern conveniences it still takes women
like at least an hour like to look
halfway decent this Victorian era stuff
is just a holdover from the from the
medieval period you know that was going
on in the medieval period all these
Ladies Single Ladies if they were
[ __ ] nobility or royalty they had a
[ __ ] gaggle of [ __ ] girlfriends
that did their hair and [ __ ] did
their nails and all their clothes
because they have all these clothes they
didn't have washing machines yeah she
can't take care of all this [ __ ] she
needs a whole [ __ ] yeah they got a
whole second pit crew yeah you know what
I mean and they better be yeah
it is like it's exactly what it is it's
the pit crew and they better be your
friends
you know what I mean so it was and and
here's the thing that was a high ranking
job yeah that wasn't some [ __ ] even
though it sounds like it would be no
because the alternative is [ __ ]
working your ass in that damn field yeah
working in a stables mucking out [ __ ]
stalls uh hooking that kind of [ __ ] yeah
if you were a handmaiden that was an
executive position
you got to eat the same food that the
[ __ ] lady ate
yeah they all ate the same food they
lived in the same [ __ ] facility yeah
they got to live in a nice house yeah
probably like the shitty drafty rooms
but still still a lot better yeah a lot
better sleeping out with the [ __ ]
pigs right sleeping in the states
sleeping in the Stables that's kind of
where they came from but I think the
thing is is that most of those
handmaidens didn't come from that they
were Noble daughters
you were in other words if you came from
a [ __ ] wealthy family you were
positioning your daughters together yeah
they did like I said it was it was
whatever the Prime Minister like
whatever party that was it was always
like other party people or like the
wives of some of the politicians so that
that's the position the handmaidens
weren't slaves right they were lower
upper class
and their dads had to [ __ ] weasel
them into there
you know
Zach says first time getting laid at 20
and knowing the era probably no
masturbating how did the orgasm not kill
her
they were diddling
I mean as much as as much as they said
like that they weren't it's like I don't
believe that um listen to them
bashful [ __ ] they're bashful
[ __ ] I kind of feel like the
victorians are one of those kind of uh
people that everybody talks about like
how students and upright they were they
were probably like the biggest freaks
ever yeah right I kind of Imagine
because they wanted everybody to think
they were all like all the picture of
propriety and everything I imagine they
weren't even even
fairly successful farming families they
all slept in the goddamn same room yeah
you know what I mean and the parents
were continually having children
there's no way you could hide the fact
that you were [ __ ] in front of your
kids yeah they knew it was up I mean
everybody that's what you did everybody
knew everybody's bodily functions at any
time like you were watching everybody
[ __ ] you were watching Everybody
pooping you were watching everything
yeah they weren't as things but yeah it
wasn't as prudish as people really think
it was they probably pretended to be
prudish
but their version of being prudish was
just some kind of ritualistic [ __ ] the
reality was is that they were [ __ ]
out in public and [ __ ] [ __ ] and
you know in the same room with other
people and it was it wasn't it wasn't
like you're thinking yeah it was in the
1950s I really didn't think I don't
think they had anything like the modern
conception of privacy
no which is very that's really
interesting to me yeah like I'm just
interested in that kind of stuff I don't
I don't think I could have lived back
then because that would have been like
there are still countries like that if
only China has no concept of privacy I
mean like if you're used to it it's
different but it's just kind of like
nowadays everybody's kind of used to you
know get having your own space like you
know you have sex away from you don't
want people like looking at you I mean
you know unless you're into that yeah
some people aren't yeah just because
they're [ __ ] and you see it that
doesn't mean it isn't it isn't improper
right so yeah you're you're you're
you're you're you're you're you're
casting your own modern assumptions into
these situations well they were you like
I said they were used to it so it wasn't
weird to them right it wasn't weird
think about it like it wasn't weird
maybe for the ladies of the bed chamber
it wasn't weird to see Victoria like pop
in a squat on the chamber pot yeah that
was just what you did or masturbating
yeah maybe that too they might have
helped her you don't know yeah that's
the thing you don't know and maybe that
wasn't even weird yeah like we're kind
of like being part of her Duty part of
their dude
like it sounds funny but like it's
probably they were probably like yeah
that's just kind of I don't know if it's
true but I'm just saying I could [ __ ]
rationalize it using Victorian methods
if you're doing it to yourself that
might be a sin but if you have a servant
doing it for you it's just more normal
and that's more proper because it's not
you're not it's not sinful right I could
yeah I can see that work around actually
my rational it's a loophole because it's
not your responsibility
it's more like a medical procedure yeah
which they did that they did yeah well
that's where the whole like thing
because they had doctors come in and
like do they were they didn't even call
it masturbation they didn't even like
call it anything like that right there's
like they what they call like relaxation
relaxation stuff like that
dehysterifying them right and weird [ __ ]
like they were jerking them off they're
jerking them off yeah with a vibrator
yeah foreign
[Laughter]
magic wand the pocket rocket yeah
so it probably stands to reason that
that goes way back into the 1800s yeah
so that may have been one of the
responsibilities that he's handmaids I
kind of suspect that is to do these
medical procedures to keep [ __ ] um
hysteria yeah what they were hysteria
keep hysteria at Bay
hahaha gotta maintain the sanity of the
mind yeah and they're just looking at it
in a different way they're still getting
each other off though yeah there's
probably one way just her
yeah I don't yeah I don't know you never
know but never got another one petting
her hair
holding her hand and they're talking to
us okay just let it out just let it out
you know they're doing it
okay it's all over
they're gonna read They're Gonna
rationalize it like you said maintenance
just just like the gentleman of the bed
chamber that come in and do and
maintenance
got a special imma blow you suit with
this [ __ ] special I blow these gloves
on
hair all trim
I'm imagining I I imagine I know this is
a little bit past this era but I was
imagining somebody that looked like
somebody from a barbershop quartet like
I said that was a little later I was
imagining a grass Isle little [ __ ]
dude like Prince like a little one
little white English prince you know
what I mean [ __ ] you know [ __ ] and
he's obviously gay but you're not
supposed to notice that you know what I
mean and [ __ ] he comes in and [ __ ]
takes care of you it's probably some
[ __ ] like that just
because that's
because they did [ __ ] like that come on
yeah they did things like that they did
they just rationalized it in a different
way yeah
if you saw it today you go yeah yeah you
had a [ __ ] Queen yeah you had a
little gay dude come in and blow you and
you're calling it a medical procedure
yeah you know like dude just call it
what it is seriously it's okay but like
back then it wasn't okay so you had you
still did it but you had to like call it
something you had to call it something
you had to call it something else yeah I
don't have proof that that happened but
I'm just theorizing allegedly it's a
legend
I like to imagine that that's probably
it wouldn't shock me it wouldn't no it
wouldn't surprise me because people are
not different the whole handmaiden thing
though I'm guarantee you what our
description was that's probably what it
was yeah I could see that and that
probably goes way way back yeah probably
goes back to ancient Egypt Rome
definitely
definitely well and Rome talked about it
well the thing about it too is that you
have to think even up until this era
most of the time I mean Victoria and
Albert were kind of an exception because
they actually like really dug each other
but most Royal marriages were of
convenience so you know they would [ __ ]
like to produce an heir but I think a
lot of time it was just like dutiful
yeah like you'd go in there like once a
month or whatever and be like yeah do
the pumping thing and it's like yeah
maybe we'll get pregnant this month bye
you know what I mean I think I can feel
like more it was more like that so in
the medieval period
um most of the most of the uh the
kingdoms that came out in the visit you
know like the ostrogoths and Visigoths
and all this these little kingdoms that
came out of the [ __ ] collapsing Roman
Empire considered themselves to be fully
Roman and they did a lot of Roman stuff
still for a long long time so it stands
to reason that in the Victorian period
they're still doing things from the
medieval period that came from Rome
so it would have been all the basically
what we would call sex slavery or sex
servicing probably still going on
I would imagine yeah I mean yeah
why wouldn't it yeah why wouldn't that
be going on
they had the money Jeff here it said now
I'm imagining Dame Judy Dench as Queen
Victoria telling Conroy to get the [ __ ]
out of here using Jenny's dialogue and
now I'm also picturing that so thank you
I love Jade I love Judy Dench but yeah
so that would be super funny maybe she
did say that I don't know I don't think
they said [ __ ] but well they did but I
don't know if they said it I'm sure they
said it in private I mean I would be
surprised if they did so uh so yeah so
Victoria you know she's married now
she's pregnant all the time she's kind
of like miserable
um and that may or may not have
contributed to her finally kicking her
[ __ ] mom out of the palace because
like she's like [ __ ] I'm married now
get the [ __ ] out of here she didn't like
throw her out in the street it's you
know what I mean uh she actually went to
she got a house uh you know elsewhere in
London and then after
um Victoria's aunt died who was Princess
Augusta then Victoria actually got her
both of her houses so it's not like like
I said she didn't like throw her out on
the street or nothing like that but
she's like look I don't want my mom in
the house anymore so she lived through
I'm married now get the [ __ ] out so she
also said oh my phone's buzzing
I don't know he's calling me it's
probably like uh
sales person
now uh in 1840 somebody asked earlier
like how many assassination attempts
there had been uh there were several I
think there were seven but there might
have been more than that so the first
one happened in 1840.
um and this was not too long after she
had first uh married Albert and she was
actually pregnant at this point so this
was like her first pregnancy
so she's in her carriage with Albert and
she's going to visit her mom because
Albert was actually trying to like get
them to get along which kind of worked
out later on but you know what I mean
so they're in the carriage and a kid who
is 18 years old named Edward Oxford like
jumped out and shot at her like while
she was in The Carriage now he shot
twice but he either they don't know if
he actually like just missed both times
like he's just a rotten shot or if the
gun didn't have any like shot in it
so he actually got caught and he got
tried for high treason
but was found not guilty by reason of
insanity they throw him in an insane
asylum and then later sent him to
Australia so there's that
now one thing that this assassination
attempt did was made Victoria very very
popular for a brief time because you
know everybody she I mean she had just
gotten married and she was pregnant and
had this 18 year old kid like jump out
and shoot at her like while she's in the
carriage I mean you know everybody kind
of felt sympathetic to her say you know
what I mean uh so but this at this point
too this was like she was still like
unpopular because of the whole Hastings
thing like the thing about that
you know the the woman with the
abdominal growth and also the whole bed
chamber crisis thing so this actually
helped get her like popular again the
fact that she got shot at
so her first daughter who was also named
Victoria uh was born in 1840. and as I
mentioned before the queen absolutely
hated being pregnant like everything
about it she just thought was disgusting
and gross and she just thought it was
awful and she was like depressed all the
time
um but
I don't know man they didn't really have
good birth control back then and I guess
her and Albert [ __ ] a lot so because
like I said they had nine kids like over
over their marriage yeah I can't even
imagine quiverpool family that's yeah
and unlike a lot of families at the time
like they all live to adulthood now some
of them did she did outlive several of
them but the ones that died like they
died as adults you know what I mean like
from various diseases she didn't lose
any as babies
um so yeah that's [ __ ] crazy I just
can't even I can't imagine and honestly
like all of her kids uh eventually ended
up marrying into other royal families in
Europe interestingly and she might have
been I don't know she was like the
ultimate source of this but Victoria
carried the hemophilia Gene
and that ended up affecting 10 of her
male descendants including uh the son of
the Russian Czar Nicholas II
so I don't know
I mean I'm sure it had been around since
then but she was actually like
responsible for like being the carrier
for like a lot of the hemophilia that
came out in the family later on which is
kind of interesting to me but I mean
well because yeah she you got it in your
family don't you have it yeah yeah right
yeah yeah
um my grandfather found it
and well my family is it I don't know
how
um unusual this is I've heard that it's
very unusual because usually hemophilia
women are carriers and men like
manifested because of the way that it
genetically like works but in my family
um my grandfather had it and passed it
to several of my uh
ants so two of my aunts who are twins
have it like full-blown actually maybe
three of them two of the Twins and one
of the other sisters has it and also
um my cousin's son has it as well so it
runs in the family and
I've always been I've never been tested
but it's weird I always thought
hemophilia was like a one like either
you have it or you don't but apparently
it's like a percentage because in my on
my mother's side of the family like a
lot of them have like a certain
percentage of
hemophilia so it's kind of like they
have to be like my one of my aunts they
they told her her whole life like look
you have really bad hemophilia she was
eating her and her twin were
um in like medical studies because
usually it doesn't manifest in women
usually it only manifests in men like
women are just like the carriers of the
gene but they actually had it like
full-blown and so they were like do they
did all these medical studies on them
when they were kids and they told them
they're like look don't ever have
children because you'll probably like
bleed to death you know what I mean
um but one of them did and she had all
kind of problems like they had to do
like blood transfusions and everything
like that I mean I've never had
I've never been tested and I've never
but I've never had anything happen that
would make me think that I had it enough
that it would like [ __ ] kill me my
normal Hollywood friend from a military
academy if I can Brian hackett's in the
in the [ __ ] um uh chat room he's
saying my mustache is good my beard good
thanks Brian yeah I still haven't seen
the new your new movie yet
oh we got we got a sex spot sex boss sex
box yeah somebody's getting rid of him
hey yeah I I haven't seen the Gina
Chrono flick yeah the terror on the
Prairie
maybe you can send me a uh a link to see
it for free I don't know but I wanted to
see it never got around to see it we'll
review it
it's behind that [ __ ] paywall I just
should have never done that yeah well
yeah Sabrina said uh I think they did
have a form of condoms back then they
did I mean condoms go back thousands of
years uh as far as I know but he didn't
tell her because they wanted her to have
a lot of children I think that's
I don't know like I I saw a couple
documentaries about this and one of the
documentaries said that Albert's family
they specifically said hey get her
pregnant and like have her pregnant and
having kids all the time so she can't
like run [ __ ]
so I don't know if that's true or not
Brian said he had no idea you were 50 he
thought you were 35. yeah no she looks
young
took her to the club the other day I was
talking to a friend of mine [ __ ] you
know he he went on HRT he's feeling
great and I said look at Jan man she's
50 because I know she looks amazing and
uh he's my agent maybe a little bit
maybe a year or two older
I'm not sure I don't know how old he is
I've never asked yeah you're staying in
good shape
and take [ __ ] you know
hormone replacement therapy it works
plus like I said we you know we've
talked about it before we stay out of
the Sun and we don't do well we don't do
like old people [ __ ] stay positive
um keep weight off
yeah that helps um
hormones will work most of it just has
testosterone and uh occasional [ __ ]
touch-ups with
anabolics
yeah it'll extend it a bit you know
you're gonna die eventually anyway
just well yeah you want to die strong
and pretty
yeah Brian said yeah he was talking
about seeing my uh cable and how he grew
up cast yeah I've posted a video earlier
about
uh the early days of cable TV and like
how I ended up seeing time after time
from like 1979. yeah I was around for
all of that so I was I was born in like
1972. so yeah
me and Hackett went to scma Southern
California Military Academy that's we
were raised there
Signal Hill California it was the
military academy it was kind of out of
the Sylvester Stallone movie Over the
Top
probably the inspiration for evil speak
remember that [ __ ] show remember that
show Brian evil speak we were in [ __ ]
school when that came out we all wanted
to see that [ __ ] oh that movie yeah yeah
we love that school it was a fun school
it's like being in the Boy Scouts and
being in school at the same time it was
good yeah it was cute it was it was good
it was good school loved it and uh
anyway if is there any if there's any
way you can um
uh get me a link to uh tear on the
Prairie so I could watch it because I
can't I can't find it I can't rent it
anywhere
we'll review it
foreign
yeah I've been wanting to see that for a
while like you can um that's on regular
streaming services I think as far as I
know
I thought it was on
Hulu or Amazon Prime but maybe it might
not be on there anymore we gotta check
you gotta check
um did you have Z Channel Jenny uh I
don't think so I don't think so yeah I
know how cm is gone they [ __ ] tore it
down gone
the end of an era it was there it says
the [ __ ] what the 20s
Brian said he works with the director of
evil speak a few years ago oh did he
yeah yeah I love that movie we saw it
did we review that yeah we did yeah we
liked it yeah good movie
what a weird ass movie weird movie
summoning the devil through a [ __ ]
Apple II computer
when they're an apple 2E I think it
might have or is it just an apple might
have been I can't count the number of
times that I accidentally summon demons
yeah it's a good place to say we ain't
back in the day it's a good flick I was
watching and I was like the floppy discs
and I was like whoever [ __ ] made this
movie
somehow knew about scma or [ __ ] Army
Naval Academy it was kind of like that
but it was good good flick
how did he come up with that that idea
Brian
how does anyone come up with any idea
so yeah we were talking about oh okay he
said he's going to send a link in my
messenger or email okay thank you very
much Mrs Evans already party said just
got here a great topic see told you
at the beginning of the show you didn't
see it but Tom was like this topic
sounds really boring yeah he said at the
very he said tell me this topic and I
was like man [ __ ] up yeah
okay so we were talking about hemophilia
because we kind of got distracted
because I said yeah hemophilia runs in
my family as well damn it uh you know
some a lot of my aunts have it
so 1842 uh Victorian Albert actually
went to Scotland for the first time and
they were really into it they even got
like
um they bought like all of this property
there and they built well okay so they
bought Balmoral and then they also did
like a neo-gothic castle for the family
there and that is actually still there
like it's still a private residence for
the royal family to this day and
Victoria would like go to Scotland and
she she just went there all the time and
like went to the Highland Games and all
she got all into the kind of [ __ ] and
her being there all the time actually
did promote a lot of like tourism to the
area so you know I guess they did kind
of like like that now interestingly
because
Victorian Albert
went to Scotland and they had another
property on the Isle of Wight and you
know the the fact that they went there
all the time it's almost kind of like I
feel like prior to this like the the
monarchs had been more present in sort
of like the center of things but the
fact that Victoria and Albert acted more
like
I don't want to say a normal couple
because they always had like a [ __ ] ton
of money but the fact that they would go
away to these other houses for like
privacy to get out of the public eye and
things like that I think that made
people like just regular people like
relate to them more because they acted
more like regular middle class people
you know what I'm saying like obviously
they had like a [ __ ] ton more money but
they were acting more like a
middle-class couple would act it's like
oh we're gonna go here for privacy for a
little while and stuff like that whereas
like previous monarchs I don't think had
really worried about that so much so I
think that they kind of I think that was
one of the things that led to the royal
family eventually becoming what it is
today I think this was kind of like the
the Genesis of that where they were
starting to act more like regular people
you know with [ __ ] tons of money
rather than being like above everybody
else Ken do you know what I'm saying it
was kind of like that kind of thing kind
of like representatives of the
figureheads of the people right they're
trying but it's like the fact that they
were like normal it's like hey we gotta
get out of here for a little while and
like go decompress like at our house in
Scotland like bye
um people could relate to that I feel
like you know what I'm saying because
they weren't just like in the public eye
all the time
so um
I kind of and also I think too like
Albert was real into like you know uh
you know science and things like that
like things that were going on at the
time but Victoria had very similar
tastes to a lot of her subjects like she
was really into like going to the circus
and she would go to like the wax museum
and she would read Charles Dickens and
stuff like that which was like something
that regular people were doing so I kind
of feel like that people could relate to
them in a way that they had not been
able to relate to the royal family like
the monarchs before so like I said I
think that was like a big cultural
change which is one of the reasons why I
said that she was so influential just
culturally and I don't think she meant
to be that that was just like the way
that she was
um also not really like I said not real
religious not real prudish which I kind
of feel like a lot of people think a
tribute to a lot of people from the
Victorian era but her and Albert were
like real into like you know artwork of
like nudes and stuff like that I kind of
feel like they were kind of secret
freaks you know what I'm saying uh yeah
so there was that uh so here's another
assassination attempt 29th of May 1842
uh Victoria is again riding in a
carriage and she's on uh the mall in
London and then a guy named John Francis
jumps out aims a pistol at her uh but
the gun didn't fire man guns back then
were like [ __ ] I'm gonna kill you
what year is this 1842. yeah it's just
Captain ball yeah unreliable because the
first one the first attempt yeah also
two shots and yeah he either missed or
it didn't fire yeah
now so quality control problems yeah and
[ __ ] moisture and you couldn't keep
anything loaded for very long if it was
loaded more in a couple days you were
risking misfire you had to shoot the
[ __ ] gun every day yeah if you loaded
it you had to shoot it at the end of the
day
then reload it because it would get yeah
yeah you could you couldn't stay loaded
for [ __ ] two or three days you start
risking misfires [ __ ] that was the uh
the way old guns were yeah
the chemistry wasn't there they didn't
have what they needed to make chemicals
stable I mean lucky for Victoria because
it seemed like a lot of people shot at
her yeah but none of them
none of the guns went off or they missed
wildly so there's that yeah she was
probably hard to get in England even
back in those days so the guy had a
loaded gut it stayed loaded for a
[ __ ] long period of time not not like
the West
yeah I mean in the old west [ __ ] it
was easy to get less a lot less controls
and then you could shoot you could you
could step out beside your house and
[ __ ] shoot off a [ __ ] round every
day to clear the [ __ ] weapon out and
then reload so yeah they're in a more
urban environment so chances of misfire
under those technological limitations
far greater
so yeah it's not something like
it's not a plot point you know I mean
it's not like something out of a movie
that's the way it really was back then
oh somebody said somebody said Thank You
Bryce thank you very much the street I
live on is named after Queen Victoria
I grew up learning a Haka Haka Haka My
Tribe has that honors her okay what kind
of trap is that
yeah I'm not really yeah you sent us
some more details on there what kind of
what kind of tribe that is this is
Evan's already party he said with the
New Zealand dollars so he he must be
Maori must be Maori yeah maybe that
maybe okay this is having badasses up
there
Mrs Evans already party said with the
corsets they were the ball would have
bounced off probably
all the [ __ ] 50 layers of clothes
they had on
seriously I served in the 101st Airborne
Division yeah no no Maori though
it was all Samoans and micronesians and
um uh Hawaiians and uh island boys are
[ __ ] crazy y'all are cannibals
[ __ ] beating each other's asses and
eating each other [ __ ]
we had a Samoan our platoon
I had a Samoa in our platoon when it was
up in Korea and a bunch of micronesians
and [ __ ] he couldn't stand in
micronesians and it
and [ __ ] one of them was Gordon who's
a friend of mine and he back there and
he goes you have to understand something
these guys here they taste great [ __ ]
because they would eat micronesians
[ __ ] funny [ __ ] man the cannibals
these guys are delicious these guys are
delicious
hey like oh man [ __ ] you it tastes just
like a chocolate chicken yeah
that's how it was not that I would know
it's Warrior culture [ __ ] man you're
gonna end up in an Airborne unit a
Ranger Army Ranger
so here's something that I thought was
funny so she's in her carriage some
[ __ ] pops out and like fires a
gun at her but it doesn't shoot
now the guy gets away but the next day
Victoria tells the guy driving the
carriage let's go the same route but
we'll have more people with us and we'll
go a little bit faster because they
wanted the guy to try and shoot at her
again so they could catch him
um she's like yeah we're gonna we're
gonna like kind of draw him out and that
actually worked like the dumbass
you know jumped out again like the next
day and shot at her also
um and uh they actually like uh caught
him like playing clothes policemen got
him and he also got convicted of high
treason now a couple days uh he got a
death sentence but it got commuted to
life
now two days after he got the death
sentence which I'm not really sure like
how long later that was another guy
named John William Bean also tried
shooting at the queen because like I
said like everybody's shooting at her
and she seems like to
she seems like pretty uh chill about it
I mean I don't know but she was just
kind of like Yep they're shooting at me
whatever now so this guy like fires a
pistol at her but apparently
he didn't really have any real shot I
don't
he put like tobacco and paper in there
I'm not really sure what he thought that
was gonna do maybe it was just like a
symbolic gesture or something but uh
yeah it obviously didn't do Jack so she
was just kind of like all right whatever
uh there was another one there was
actually another uh assassination
attempt in 1849 and in that case it was
an Irish guy named William Hamilton and
he again fired a powder-filled pistol at
her carriage as it went along uh
Constitution Hill in London
um but again nothing happened she didn't
get hurt or nothing like that now the
only time she was ever injured quote
unquote during an assassination attempt
was in 1850 and she actually got in that
case I don't even think she was in a
carriage
um but she was actually like this crazy
dude
um he was an ex-army guy and his name
was Robert pate and he just like came
and started wailing on her like jumped
on her like and hit her in the head with
a cane but it didn't hurt her that bad I
think it just like bruised her head and
like smushed her Bonnet or something
like that
um you know so nothing bad happened the
Irish guy that shot at her he got seven
years and I think Pate that guy that hit
her with the cane also got seven years
like they just kind of like sent them
um transportation does that mean they
sent them to Australia or
I don't know they didn't none of them
got death sentences though which is
crazy like shooting at a monarch you'd
think that that would be kind of like a
bigger deal but all right like whatever
but none of them they some of them got
sent to Australia but that's about it
but yeah so she got shot at a bunch of
times but seems to have
uh taking it with remarkable alacrity
she's just kind of like Yep they're
shooting at me
but she never got hurt though I guess
because the gun sucked
she did get hit in the head in the head
with the cane but that's about it
yeah Bryce confirmed that he is Maori
yeah yeah
okay uh Brian Hackett sent me uh sent me
a gift on my messenger okay I'll check
it in a bit bro
I probably need some more ice than that
I'll get you something and then after
that if I still
I might have some more whiskey but I
want to finish that up first if we have
any of that whiskey left I got whiskey
no she doesn't want ice and then I'll
give you whiskey later okay and then
whiskey later whiskey later okay
so 1845 uh probably most people and
particularly in the United States you
know this because we had a lot of Irish
immigration right around this time
because Ireland got the potato blight
big old Potato Famine from Ireland which
like I said was the cause of a lot of uh
Irish people moving to the United States
because they were starving over there
now uh so over the next four years from
1845 to 1849 over a million Irish people
died and another million [ __ ] off out
of Ireland and most of them came here to
the United States
now um Victoria got I don't know if she
necessarily got blamed for it but she
got associated with it they called her
the famine Queen
now there was actually a rumor I think
this actually maybe started a little bit
later
the rumor was and I guess this started
later after she was dead like to kind of
like [ __ ] on her a little bit the story
went that it's like oh she only gave
five pounds of Aid to the Irish and then
the same day gave five pounds to like a
dog shelter
uh that is absolutely not true uh that
acts that's a myth that happened like
after she died
in real life in 1847 she actually gave 2
000 pounds which nowadays is about 178
000 pounds
um
or actually maybe
it says equivalent to between 178 000
and 6.5 million pounds in 2016 money
so she gave that out of her own money to
the British relief Association like to
help out the Irish so she did do some
[ __ ] about it I don't know if she
necessarily
like I said the thing about Victoria is
that she seemed to care to an extent
like she seemed to care about like
individual people and their individual
problems but like when it came to stuff
like hey the working class and their
suffering or something like that she
really didn't seem to like see that you
know what I mean like oh whatever but I
think that was more like her privilege
talking I don't think she was a mean
person it's just she didn't really know
any different hey Bryce
um I believe the correct me if I wrong
um
when the Maori served they end up in the
British army I think I think they're a
British Empire British protectorate
because we've never had any Maori in the
Army in the U.S army now when I was in
Egypt we ran across we served with the
fijians but they were also British
Empire
and uh this is when we were on the mfo
mission over in Egypt
and the fijians I I don't know how close
Fiji is
to uh to New Zealand but [ __ ] the
fijians were mad men [ __ ] them big
too big and [ __ ] crazy they were good
though real good
but uh that's all I'm gonna say about it
we didn't we didn't have any Maori and
it must be British Army gotta be yeah
Bryce said yes we did still to this day
we're British Empire British yeah
British Empire right same with the same
with Fiji
yeah probably like Fiji maybe press
similar probably
Mrs Evans already party said that's when
my Irish family came to the US like
during the Potato Famine I'm genetically
obsessed with eating potatoes because of
that famine I think probably that's when
my uh at least the Irish side of my
ancestors came over as well I think the
I mean anybody that has any Irish
ancestry I think the majority of it came
over during the after the Potato Famine
during the Potato Famine right like
during those four or five years and
there was a bunch of times that they
came
that's true but I do kind of feel like
there was a 1920s [ __ ] yeah that's
flood also that came
we're Southerners we're just kind of a
mix of a bunch of different things that
came over time
and there's going to be a when you try
to trace ancestry you can't go through
the paternal lineage because you're
neglecting all the other [ __ ] lineage
because all the females and everything
also and you're not related to one
single person of course you're related
to a dab group
so and then you go back four or five
generations and you're barely related to
these people anyway so you're just kind
of a [ __ ] genetic Mass like a swarm
you know
if you're Southern and you're white
it's a lot of Irish some British
Scottish
some German
and probably like something Hispanic
because the Spanish Empire and the
French Empire were here too so you're
going to have that in there also and
then Native American
and probably black
depending on how long you've been here
a lot a lot of people have some black
ancestry
and even if it's not visible you just
have to go back far enough
yeah
um my family does for sure
but yeah
Mrs Evans already said I was dying
laughing when y'all were talking about
being famine resistant yep I'm half
Choctaw Indian and half Irish yeah we do
not starve you gonna be fat short
[ __ ] fat
eat anything and keep weight on yeah
yeah it sucks man it's your hormonal
disposition I've been [ __ ] regulating
my own hormones manually it takes a lot
even [ __ ] artificially to [ __ ] get
fat off you
when you have our jeans
anti-starvation jeans I'm just very very
jealous of people because I've known
people in my life that were just thin
and they didn't if they ate what they
wanted they didn't really exercise all
that much but they just like constantly
stayed thin I looked at that though a
lot of times what happens is they could
be directly related to you
and have [ __ ] anti-starvation genes
but they have a gene in there that
[ __ ] allows them to produce a lot of
insulin
so they're very [ __ ] resistant to
carbohydrates they can [ __ ] break
them down a lot easier
it must be though and yes it is just the
fact that they have a good insulin Gene
and you know what race of people has
excellent insulin genes
Japanese the Japanese and the Koreans
that's why they don't really get that
fat they can eat a lot and then eat a
lot of carbs like rice and not gain a
lot of fat
good genes for it insulin production
like I said I'm jealous strong insulin
because I've seen some people that eat
twice or three times what I can eat in a
day and don't gain a pound it's like man
if I ate that I would wait 500 [ __ ]
eat a whole bag of damn candy corn and
not [ __ ] gain anything right they're
like oh my God I hate you they could
just make all kinds of insulin and just
break that sugar down
yeah Danny Rowling said uh cough cough
sumo wrestlers well yeah but I mean the
reason that sumo wrestlers are they're
like celebrities because they're they're
unusual they're unusual unusual and um
they're not just eating just rice
they're eating high protein too they eat
a lot if you see what Sumo eat on a
daily basis they're [ __ ]
you have to force yourself to eat that
much
you couldn't just eat that
go look at what they eat I mean yeah you
could eat that that's a [ __ ] lot that
they eat today there's I'm sure I
couldn't even eat a fraction of that
right it's a lot of fish it's a lot of
[ __ ] Japanese food a lot of rice
um they they drink a lot of sake
um so no that's very high calorie
if you were to eat that you'd probably
be [ __ ] twice that size
I'm sure
but yeah okay so uh so as I said so we
were talking about uh the Irish so she
actually did give a lot of money to that
although it's questionable like how much
she actually gave that much of a [ __ ]
about she did she did have a house on
Balmoral and she did seem to hang out
with like the Scottish poor uh in that
area and her and Albert also supported
the repeal of the Corn Laws uh which was
kind of a big thing and that was like
this
it was this legislation that kept uh the
price of British green like artificially
High
and they actually
um supported repealing that because that
would um help out the help out Ireland
which I've obviously been devastated by
famine but they didn't seem I mean they
just did that because it seemed like
politically expedient I feel like they
were a lot more interested in building
their house like on the Isle of Wight
and like doing more like with foreign
policy they cared about Ireland but I
think it wasn't like their main priority
you know what I mean and another thing
too was that there was a group called
The chartists who were reformists
essentially
um they were kind of more working more
toward like a democratic like more
working class type of thing like more
rights for the working class and
Victoria
um did not like them you know what I
mean she was like really uh into she
fully supported like uh repressing them
and they did a big demonstration in
London and like they and it failed and
she was like all about that you know
what I mean and she called them
worthless and wanton that's what she
called them and basically she was like
anything
that had to do with like revolutionary
anything that was like making conditions
better for the workers she thought that
that was like not a good thing because
she was always like one of her quotes
she said obedience to the laws and to
The Sovereign is obedience to a higher
power divinely instituted for the good
of the people not the Sovereign who has
equally duties and obligations so like I
said we were talking about this earlier
she was very much still like a Divine
writer Kings [ __ ] you know what
I mean she didn't really like this whole
rights for the working class type of
[ __ ] it's like we we're divinely put
here to like rule over you people God
said so because God said so
um so you know so quit causing agitation
because you're just making things worse
let me get back uh Brian no yeah if we
can if we'll if we can watch Tara on the
Prairie we'll review it I've been
wanting to see that and
um uh Bryce yeah talking about the
fijians we were impressed with the
fijians man they were badass big
um the British banned them from drinking
alcohol even when they were off duty
because they would they would kill you
they were just mean when they were drunk
and uh I got stories about that [ __ ]
Fiji and Colonel got drunk and [ __ ]
busted his way into a bar already drunk
and the British had to kick him out and
it took like six guys
and you hear saying they're [ __ ] even
more badass than the Maori I'm [ __ ]
you know yeah well you know it's
impressive to hear that because I
thought the mile were a badass too
everything I've seen about them but
they're just big The Rock [ __ ]
you know and the fijians were like that
too they were kind of darker uh darker
skinned big
um
loyal uh real professional
dangerous especially when they were
especially if they got their hands on
alcohol no resistance to alcohol
at all
kind of the same as uh
as a as as a Samoan Samoans if they got
drunk he'd be your best friend he'd turn
on you and try to kill you and they got
banned from drinking
and a lot of the units that they were in
uh just genetics I totally understand if
you [ __ ] around with any kind of drugs
or hormones there are some things that
just don't work on certain people
Islanders will get mean on that they
don't they didn't evolve with it
okay go ahead
so okay so one of the big highlights of
the reign of Victoria and Albert too it
must be said was 1851 opening of the
great exhibition this was kind of like a
big deal like I said kind of highlight
of their regime Albert actually like
organized this big international trade
show and this was kind of like symbolic
of like the you know here's like the
progress or how the progress we've made
like with the Victorian age uh they did
it was like the Crystal Palace they did
that whole
um that greenhouse building that was in
Hyde Park and it had all of the kind of
like it's kind of like the World's Fair
would be in the United States where
there's like here's all the
technological achievements that we've
made and it's like here's all the
progress that we're making and [ __ ] like
that it was like a big huge [ __ ] deal
um Victoria was like super into all the
stuff that Albert came up with with
organizing it and everything like that
now the profits that they made from the
great exhibition
um actually the money they got from that
funded what would become the South
Kensington complex of colleges and
museums and that included the museum
that would become the Victoria and
Albert Museum which is still there today
and you know
so it's kind of a famous Museum now
interestingly though
um right about the time that the Crimean
War started about 1854.
um Victorian Albert experienced uh some
waning popularity around that time
there were rumors going around uh
possibly unfounded I'm not entirely sure
that Albert was trying to influence the
government in favor of the Russians
um but as the war went on it was lasted
about two years
um there was actually so even though
they were unpopular at this start like
as the war started going on like I guess
royalist sentiment sort of like you know
started going back up again
um and I think maybe some of that was
because Victoria tried to kind of put
herself out there and she had all these
ladies and they
um kind of got together and like helped
out the wounded soldiers and uh you know
backed Florence Nightingale and she
instituted the Victoria Cross you know
like for gallantry which I think they
still uh give nowadays so she tried to
like kind of up the you know their their
public perception by going and helping
out all the wounded soldiers and
everything like that
um she also kind of did stuff like
becoming patrons of Institutions
um doing all this charity work
um you know they did like they put like
money into like educational museums and
stuff like that and they do like visits
to Industrial towns and stuff like that
which I kind of feel like a lot of
monarchs hadn't done previously they
were trying to make themselves I guess
seem more relevant because they were
afraid because at this point in Britain
there was um a tie toward more like
Democratic or more kind of like a more
constitutional Republican type of thing
rather than a monarchy and they were
trying to make themselves seem more
relevant or like hey we're working and
we're earning our keep you know what I
mean you guys are giving us all this
money and we're giving it to Charities
and we're doing things in exchange for
the money that we're getting rather than
just laying around because prior to this
I kind of feel like the reason that the
monarchy had
that they were looking at it that the
public was looking at as scants was that
they felt like oh there have been all
these like sex scandals and financial
scandals and it's like it seemed like oh
you know you're taking all of our money
and you're just laying around being
indolent and like you know knocking up
prostitutes and like whatever the [ __ ]
they were doing and they're like what
are we paying you people for uh you know
what I mean so they wanted to seem I
think Victoria and Albert wanted to see
more useful you know like they weren't
just like laying around spending
everyone's money or just being like
degenerate you know what I mean like
we're actually doing something that's
for the good of the country so like I
said I kind of feel like they were the
first Royals that actually did that and
you know it that kind of like continued
into the present day
in March of 1861 Victoria's mother died
now uh Victoria and her mother like I
said had a very contentious relationship
uh they had kind of reconciled somewhat
like by the time she died Victoria was
actually there uh at her bedside when
she passed away
um after she died Victoria started
reading through her mom's papers
and discovered that privately I guess
she'd never told her this to her face
but Victoria's mom uh apparently like
really really loved her and but had
never told her this I guess so Victoria
felt really bad and then hated Conroy
that douche even more because she
started feeling well maybe Conroy was
the one that had come between them like
Conroy had influenced her mother and
like made her be a [ __ ] or an [ __ ]
just like he was and robbed them of the
relationship that they might have had
otherwise
now uh because she got really really
upset like that after her mother died
and she's like oh well we're never gonna
repair the relationship now
um she kind of like took I don't know if
she necessarily took to her bed but she
was just kind of like didn't really want
to do anything because she was like so
bummed out so Albert actually ended up
taking on most of her you know queenly
duties or whatever even though he was
actually kind of like suffering from
some ill health himself he had like a
lot of chronic uh stomach problems
now in August of that year this was
1861. Victorian Albert went to visit
their son who was uh Albert Edward who
is the prince of Wales they actually
called him birdie not birdie like you
know bye Bye Birdie but birdie like
b-e-r-t-e-t-i-e
now he was actually uh doing some Army
Maneuvers near Dublin
now while they were there visiting him
they found out like Albert found out
that um
apparently his son birdie had been a
[ __ ] an actress in Ireland and uh
everybody was talking about it so like
the rumor was getting around
so basically uh the dad was like okay
[ __ ] this kid uh so he goes to Cambridge
where his where he was studying and
confronted him about it
so on this trip though Albert got even
sicker
and then he got diagnosed with typhoid
fever and he ended up dying in December
of 1861. now obviously because Victoria
and Albert had been so close and had
been so much in love with one another
Victoria was absolutely like [ __ ]
grief-stricken when he died and she also
it should be said kinda blamed her son
for killing her husband because it's
like you know if if he hadn't been so
worried about you and [ __ ] that
actress and had to come out there and
yell at you and [ __ ] like that like he
might still be alive kind of situation
so there was that I don't know if she
ever forgave birdie but she did actually
like blame him a little bit for killing
her husband
now when he died
uh that was the end of what they called
the albertine monarchy now
I mean his influence on her uh persisted
actually he had kind of like changed
I don't know if he changed her entire
personality but he changed a lot of her
political sympathies and you know she
really kind of
I don't know he influenced like pretty
much everything that she did like going
forward so now that he was gone she was
just kind of like you know at a little
bit of a loss and after he died she sank
into like this horrible horrible
depression now she went into seclusion
pretty much uh after a while they
started calling her the Widow of Windsor
so she went into state of mourning very
famously were black for the remainder of
her life uh so which was a long time
um and I mentioned this before but
because she wouldn't come out and about
um she would just kind of like sit
around and be bummed out and she ate all
the time so she got like pretty fat you
know what I mean if you can as you can
see from later paintings and photographs
and she wasn't big she was only four
foot eleven so she was a little bitty
rotund girl
and uh and then the fatter she got like
the less she wanted to go out in public
you know what I mean so it was kind of
like a vicious cycle uh and also this is
pretty this is kind of weird I don't
know it's not weird it's just kind of
it's sad but every night uh where they
lived she would have them lay out
Albert's clothes on the bed as though he
was gonna get up the next day and put
them on and then every morning like they
the people would come in and like put
fresh water in the Basin like he was
gonna use it and she also had a
photograph of him which this is [ __ ]
up like it's not weird like sleeping in
a room with like a photograph of like
your dead spouse that's not weird
but what was weird was that the
photograph of him that she had in her
bedroom that she slept next to like for
the rest of her life was of him dead
like it was head and shoulders of him
like that had been taken after he died
the victorians man they were a little
bit weird well in their defense
photography was rare and expensive it
was yeah and I like I know that's kind
of why people say it's like oh why'd
they take pictures of dead babies and
[ __ ] like that but that's why that's why
it was rare and expensive and and you
were lucky to get a photograph every
three or four years if somebody died
they're like look we gotta take a
picture of them before because it's the
last time I'm ever gonna see them you're
never gonna see him again so that's what
they're doing yeah same thing with the
babies yeah it's sad when you think
about it that's yeah like like I said if
you don't really think about the context
yeah it's super weird and creepy like
why would you take a picture of a dead
baby and like the weirdest ones too is
that sometimes they have pictures where
sometimes the babies are alive but
sometimes they're dead too but they
don't want the mom in the picture so the
mom just like wears this black
cloth over her but you can still tell
there's a person there it's like just
holding the baby like on the nerves the
legs that's so creepy It's just sad
they're just trying to hold on to a
person that's gone yeah they're trying
to get a picture of it it's not creepy
when you read about like what the
context was but if you don't know the
context yeah it's super creepy let's
just see what the little babies would
look like it's yeah it make it kind of
make you choke up if you think about it
yeah it is it is very very sad it is
very sad because like I said you know
photography wasn't it's not like now
where you could take 500 pictures on
your phone yeah it's like back then it
was a big deal and it's like you had a
baby and then like a couple days later
they died and you're like well [ __ ] you
know we need a picture to remember right
the baby bye because you know so that's
that's why they did it
but so nowadays it wouldn't be so
sentimental they'd be God [ __ ] that baby
we'll have another one
back then I think people people would
still be centered yeah babies
show pictures of it but back then they
were trying to freeze that moment in
time
and trying to memorialize that that
person yeah so it was it was respect
yeah you know Rebecca said maybe she
needed the photo to remind her that he
was dead when her grief used to mentally
mess with her where she may have
daydreamed of him still living maybe
that's what it was but it's like it
seems strange that she would have his
clothes laid out every day as though he
was still alive but then sleep next to a
picture of him dead I don't know I just
thought that was like a little bit
strange but like I said you know
whatever I said I'm not inside of her
head and it's like really sad for her
and stuff but yeah so
she um she had a hard time like uh
getting over his death I mean and I
think that's one of the things that
she's actually most famous for
was this long period of morning that she
went through now she did actually get
out of her depression but she was still
kind of like partially retired she
really didn't
have the enthusiasm anymore for doing
any of the kind of like ceremonial
functions that you were supposed to do
like if you were Queen and pretty much
like almost half the year I don't know
if it was half the year but maybe like a
third of the year she would go to like
their house on the Isle of Wight or
their house in Scotland and she would
just kind of hole up there because she
just didn't want to deal with it and I
kind of feel like a lot of the the
ministers and stuff like that were
getting annoyed with it because they're
like look you're still kind of like the
Monarch and you're still kind of like a
head of state and we'd like to be able
to like consult you about things but
you're never around
um they gave her some time like
obviously for grieving but after a while
they started to kind of get tired of it
and like the public started to get tired
of it too because they're like look our
tax dollars are paying for you and
you're just kind of like mooning around
at your house in Scotland and like not
doing anything so I kind of feel like
that maybe contributed to
the burgeoning feeling that maybe you
know in the public that they didn't
really need the monarchy I mean I think
even around this time period like one
like hilarious person even hung a for
rent sign on the gates of Buckingham
Palace which I thought was very funny
because they're like look we're we're
paying your salary and like you're not
even here most of the time like why do
we even need you
now uh throughout the 1860s like I said
you know she's a widow now
she started Victoria started relying
more heavily on a manservant from
Scotland I think she had known him
previously because I think he worked for
her husband to some degree but he was a
Scottish fella named John Brown
now uh rumors of a romantic relationship
which I think are probably pretty
founded I don't know if I want to say
that like outright but it does seem that
that's what was going on
um there were even Rumors in a couple
books came out like after she died that
they had secretly married like without
telling anybody
um and even at the time some uh you know
newspapers and stuff like that called
her Mrs Brown like as like to kind of
like get her goat you know what I mean
because they there was the rumors that
she had secretly married him because he
was a commoner
now she actually wrote about him a lot
in her journals I think one of the
things that I think I brought this up
before one of the things she liked the
best about him is that he treated her
like a regular person like he would like
take the piss out of her like what the
[ __ ] and he was like drunk all the time
too like he seemed like a fun dude I
don't you know what I mean he just from
what I read about him like he seemed
like a fun guy and I think she liked him
because of that because he just was like
a regular
drunk Scottish dude yeah and would just
like [ __ ] with her all the time and she
just thought that was funny because
nobody treated her like that was her
person yeah and the baby they were they
maybe they were [ __ ] too I I imagine
they probably what was the age
difference I don't know I don't think
there was that big of an age difference
I think like I said he had worked for
her husband like as a manservant but I
don't I don't think there was that much
difference I think they were around the
same age maybe he was slightly younger
but I'm not really sure
yeah I kind of feel like probably and
it's free like and rightly so I mean
yeah she was a little tubby at that time
but that's okay no he had to pay
anything you know they liked each other
they liked each other
and she was and she was a widow they
can't do it right that's what I'm saying
it's like that's there's no shame no
shame
uh so yeah
so finally in 1866 Victoria goes to the
state opening of the parliament this is
the first time that she's been there
since Albert died now the following year
like after that in 1867 she actually
supported the passing of what they
called the Reform Act of 1867 which
actually extended the um I guess like
the vote or you know whatever to a bunch
more men that had been able to vote
previously but interestingly she still
didn't think women should be allowed to
vote in 1867 isn't that fascinating even
though she like ran the [ __ ] she was
like nah I don't think women should vote
figures
so by 1870 uh again like there was more
of a push toward less of a monarchy kind
of thing and more of like a Republican
or more like a democracy type of thing
and there was a big rally in Trafalgar
Square that year that actually demanded
that Victoria be removed because they
thought that they didn't need a monarchy
anymore
um So that obviously didn't go anywhere
because she did stay in power but like I
said there was just like that sentiment
was in the air like we don't need the
monarchy they wanted to go like in a
more democratic Direction
the year after that her son Birdie the
one that had [ __ ] around with the
actress and that she blamed for killing
her husband uh he was the prince of
Wales now he got typhoid which was the
same thing that had killed his dad now
Victoria at this point I think she kind
of like forgave him at this point she's
like oh my God he could die of the same
[ __ ] that are that uh you know his dad
died of but he actually recovered now
his illness though actually kind of
turned public sentiment like back toward
like she got more sympathy for that
because you know they were afraid oh my
God like her son's gonna die too like
she'd had a lot of death in her life and
I think they kind of felt bad for her
1872 there was yet another assassination
attempt while she was riding in her
character man [ __ ] can't go anywhere
she can't go anywhere she ran around her
carriage and people jumping out shoot at
her uh but this time John Brown the
Scottish uh her Scottish uh little
boyfriend was with her and he actually
jumped out the carriage like a hero and
grabbed the Assassin and uh so this
actually gained her a lot more sympathy
with the public because again somebody
was like [ __ ] shooting at her
so 1847 a new prime minister comes in
Benjamin Disraeli which I kind of feel
if you know anything about British
history you've heard that name before
now he wasn't real into like the
monarchy like having a lot of power but
he did see that the monarchy could be
seen as like a symbol of patriotism and
like just a symbol of the Empire as it
expanded because he was very into like
expanding the Empire right
and so he like went hard like on being
very Charming to Victoria like kissing
her ass one of his quotes I don't know
if this is a direct quote or if this is
like kind of like a paraphrase but one
of the things that he said was Everyone
likes flattery but when it comes to
royalty you should lay it on with a
travel that's what he said so apparently
that worked and he actually got Victoria
back into like largely into the public
eye once again by having her crowned
Empress of India in 1876 even though she
never [ __ ] went there
um I think they did ask her to go but
she sent her son in her place so she
actually was Empress of India but she
never went there
um so like I said Benjamin Israeli very
very into expanding the British Empire
and that led to a couple of little Wars
there as it will uh he had the
anglo-zulu war which happened in 1879
and the second anglo-afghan war which uh
was from 1878 to 1880. now Victoria as I
said was very much a product of her time
these she kind of saw these other
countries as
uh backward and we need to civilize them
she was very kind of
you know very very imperialist in that
way well in her defense
in those days those countries didn't
have a support infrastructure
so the
they would think that well because they
don't have sewage and running water they
can't be you know like us they can't be
civilized yet so that's what she's
talking about most likely
I mean they didn't even yeah it's
something like that like I said I don't
I never had to develop that she doesn't
seem like a mean person no she didn't
seem like a you know I'll talk [ __ ]
you'd be an American I gotta talk [ __ ]
about the British but I do that all
right that doesn't mean I don't like the
BR the British Empire overall actually
did a lot of good for the world
um
they yeah there's always going to be
some abuses and [ __ ] problems but if
you look at the countries today that
once were part of the British Empire who
are now independent they're doing good
especially India doing real good okay
and a lot of that had to do with kind of
like
the foundation of education and running
water and electricity and everything
that that the British Empire was able to
to provide for the they were developing
countries
the British Empire was a part of a lot
of countries developments
um
even in the United States we we got rid
of them
they were
overall fair to us
it's just that we kind of outgrew them
didn't want them here
a lot of it was social they didn't they
didn't respect our leaders in their
Parliament and we didn't like that you
know
um they saw us as a colony
colonists not truce not true citizens
and and but that's another thing is that
the concept of Citizen is a Roman thing
and that's we revived that in in in the
1700s early 1800s America did
they didn't really have the concept of
citizenship in in these in these uh
monarchies
it was there's the Monarch and everybody
else underneath them that's really what
it was they didn't really have
citizenship per se because
traditionally in a monarchy the citizens
didn't vote there weren't citizens they
were peasants you know so you didn't
have to worry about elections
that's all the Roman Greco-Roman concept
so
but overall the British the British
Empire was I think a force of good when
it came to spreading education and
Technology
this is Evan's Arty party said they
weren't civilized because they didn't
have tea parties
and then Tammy said if you had a flag
you could take over another country
that's another Eddie Izzard reference do
you have a flag no we don't have a
bloody flag we live here yeah
no flag no country the rules but yeah I
[ __ ] with them but the British the
British were good it was all part of the
process of the world in their day they
were real good
yeah
but yeah so uh uh so yeah that was kind
of where she was coming from
now interestingly like I said she had
she did have a lot of tragedy in her
life on the 17th anniversary of her
husband Albert dying her second daughter
Alice also died of diphtheria she was
actually 35 years old
so like I said all her kids survived to
adulthoods but a lot of them like died
fairly young like she outlived a lot of
them
in 1883 a Victoria who was then 64 years
old fell down the stairs and that left
her unable to walk for several months
and she never actually fully recovered
from this injury and had racism for the
rest of her life now for a while well
for like a week and a half uh John Brown
her little Scottish boyfriend carried
her around which must have been quite a
feat because I think she was pretty
chubby at this point but he actually
died only 10 days after this accident so
of course she was obviously really
distraught about that again she actually
had a statue of him made and put it up
at Balmoral like in Scotland like right
next to the one to Albert you know what
I mean so they were [ __ ] I'm pretty
sure they were [ __ ] uh Victoria also
had another son named Leopold and he
died when he was 30. uh he had
hemophilia again she passed it to many
of her male relatives and he actually
had a cerebral hemorrhage after he fell
that was in 1887.
now that same year 1887 the Empire
celebrated Victoria's golden jubilee
that was her 50th Anniversary as Queen
so she got like this big banquet and
like this big thing at like Westminster
Abbey and when that happened again she
got she had another surge in like
popularity and that was like a big thing
of like British patriotism and [ __ ] like
that around that time too now two days
later I think Zach referred to this
earlier two days after the Jubilee
celebration
Victoria promoted an Indian Muslim
waiter they call him a waiter or a
servant of some kind his name was Abdul
Kareem
and she uh pretty much promoted him to
be her teacher or munchie
and um supposedly he was like teaching
her like languages and stuff were
teaching her about like the Indian
culture or whatever
now her family and her advisors and
stuff like that were not having it they
thought that Abdul Kareem was a spy for
the Muslim patriotic league and was
perhaps biasing the queen against the
Hindus in India
they also complained that uh this Indian
fella was pretty much doing the same job
as John Brown had been doing so like I
said maybe the two of them were [ __ ]
I'm not sure I suspect they probably
were there's pictures of him like with
her because at this point they had
photography so I have seen like pictures
of him but I don't know if that's the
case but basically anybody anytime
anybody said something about him to her
she'd be like well you're just racist
that's basically what she would say
um I don't know but he basically like
stayed with her until uh after she died
like then he went back to India and he
got a pension like for the rest of his
life so were they [ __ ] I don't know
like a lot of people think they probably
were I don't know maybe they were why
are you saying you could be in all crew
Jenny where they [ __ ] that's her
boyfriend that's what I mean I I kind of
feel like it was it probably was and
like I said good for her yeah like she
liked him she cut his ass loose well no
he died we died okay well I mean she
well she died and then like he went back
to it again okay yeah yeah
um so basically so the Queen's eldest
daughter uh who was also named Victoria
because you know they have to name
everybody the same thing now she ended
up becoming Empress of Germany in 1888
but she got widowed like that same year
and then her son ended up becoming
Kaiser Wilhelm the second now Victoria
had actually kind of hoped that her
daughter would help to kind of like make
Germany not so German
um but Wilhelm as it turned out was uh
kind of a dick and basically that ended
up like he's kind of the one that led
Germany into World War one against some
of his British relatives it should be
noted uh in 1914.
so 1896 Victoria actually surpassed the
record of her great-grandfather George
III and became the longest reigning
monarch in British history uh obviously
since been surpassed by her
great-great-granddaughter Elizabeth II
who reigned for more than 70 years until
her death very very recently
now the following year 1897 uh the queen
celebrated her 60-year Diamond Jubilee
she was at that point 78 years old and
there was like a big huge procession
through London attended by big huge
crowds everything like that 1900 her
second son Alfred died of throat cancer
and he was only 55 years old so like I
said she outlived like a bunch of her
kids
now it's just probably junk did you
checked that recently no okay I don't
usually check it because nine times
better that's my dad call I know but
okay I mean I'll check it after it's
just it's nine times out of ten it's
just a bunch of crap okay
so now ever since Albert had died
um one of Victorious things was that she
would spend every Christmas at Osborne
house which was the house they had built
for themselves on the Isle of Wight
Now by this point in 1900 she went there
for Christmas but she was kind of [ __ ]
up I mean she had rheumatism like I said
she'd fallen down the stairs and she'd
never recovered from that
um so she couldn't really walk all that
good her eye sat she had like cataracts
so she couldn't really see all that good
and then throughout like the early part
of January like after Christmas she
started feeling like really really sick
and really weak and uh you know
basically just tired all the time [ __ ]
like that so she ended up actually dying
January 22nd 1901 at the age of 81 years
old
uh so her son and successor who was King
Edward the seventh uh was at her bedside
when she died also her grandson was
Emperor Wilhelm II now she had a big
funeral she had written uh you know
instructions for it prior and they had
kind of like a military she was A
Soldier's daughter she was head of the
army so everybody wore white instead of
black that was kind of like what they
did for this type of funeral
um I kind of laughed at this
I know this is mean but um so Edward
Wilhelm and her third son Arthur they
said helped lift her body into the
coffin so it took three guys to lift her
body into the coffin because she was she
was a big girl bigger
uh by the time she died she was she was
pretty hefty
um also she was buried with Albert's
dressing gown they put that next to her
in her coffin and a plaster cast of his
hand which I thought was very weird
uh she also had a lock of John Brown's
hair and a picture of him and they put
that in her left hand but they put a
bunch of flowers on top of it so her
family wouldn't see it which I thought
was also very funny now she also had a
wedding ring that had belonged to John
Brown's mother that John Brown had given
her which that's kind of what started
speculation that she had secretly
married John Brown and like I said she
didn't tell anybody because he was a
commoner and so maybe that's why but she
was wearing it she was buried in that
ring but they put flowers over it so
like some of the family wouldn't see it
you know what I mean so there was that
whole thing
mentioned earlier because she wrote so
much like she wrote in her journal uh
one biographer said she averaged like
2500 words a day which is that's that's
pretty good
and uh so it wasn't just letters it was
journals and all that kind of stuff so
she had 122 volumes of journals when she
died so her daughter
Beatrice uh was her literary executor
and actually like kind of copied all the
stuff over but she burned a lot of [ __ ]
too probably stuff that was like real
embarrassing
but some of the stuff has since been
recovered so they figured out a bunch of
stuff about her so as I mentioned I kind
of feel like the reason that they still
talk about Queen Victoria is this date
and I think that she didn't really do
any of this stuff
deliberately necessarily but just the
fact that she that the way that culture
kind of like uh coalesced around her I
guess she was kind of like because she
came in there weren't really a lot of
horrible scandals associated with her
she was pretty fiscally you know
responsible she didn't do anything like
all that crazy and prior to that I kind
of feel like the monarchy had been on a
downward slide just because of all the
sex scandals and all the financial
scandals and it just seemed like I feel
like the British public had gotten sick
of the monarchy because it seemed like
they were just a bunch of degenerates
who were just like laying around not
doing anything and it's like we're
paying them for just going and [ __ ]
around and you know spending all our
money and being
degenerates like I said but because
Victoria came and she was like fairly
respectable like I said there were a
couple scandals like early on but it
wasn't really that big a deal
um the fact that she kind of came in and
she had almost kind of like a normal not
normal life but a relatable life or a
life that was relatable to most of her
subjects I think that kind of
I kind of think if she hadn't come along
they might have gotten rid of the
monarchy but the fact that she came
along and kind of like restored the
respectability of it to some extent
conversely by making it less powerful
but like more like of a social thing
yeah
um so I think that her being more of
like a regular person like not a regular
person but I mean you know what I mean
I think people perceived her that way so
I think that allowed the monarchy to
continue in the more ceremonial role
that it continued you know whether
that's true or not that's how people
perceive it so I kind of feel like I
kind of feel like had she not come along
at that time and been the way she was I
kind of feel like they probably would
have just got rid of the monarchy back
then maybe not like I don't know but
that was the impression that I got but
because she made the monarchy
simultaneously less
politically powerful but at the same
time more culturally or socially
relevant because it looked like oh
they're just like regular people and
they are actually doing things like
they're actually like trying to you know
do things with Charities or like trying
to do things like more in a cultural
sort of way and I think that that kind
of like softened The public's
um perception of them a little bit and
that's why they were kind of still
around so I think that's maybe why they
were so influential like why she's so
influential to this day because the
weird thing about it is that she really
did not seem to give two shits about all
of the Wonders and the technological
advances that were happening at this
time I mean this was she was right
around the same time as like Darwin's
theory of evolution she was right around
the same time as like the Industrial
Revolution like all of that kind of
stuff but it's like she didn't really
seem to give that much of a crap about
it and honestly she didn't really have
much patience for democracy she didn't
really have any patience for
technological innovation or any of the
big cultural changes that were happening
she didn't get into any of that stuff
and yet she still seemed emblematic of
her era which I thought was very very
interesting like that juxtaposition just
seemed very interesting to me
um but I don't know like what do you
guys think about it because I don't know
that was I think that was the most
interesting thing that I kind of gleaned
from all of the stuff that I read about
her you know what I mean yeah I think
I'm hungry you think you're hungry yeah
you wanna uh you want a quesadilla uh
sure why not make some quesadillas
I got all the stuff to make with pork
tenderloin and everything in it all
right that'll sound good yeah poor
dandelion cheese a little bit of beans
in it yeah okay we can do that sure
show's over
and shut that [ __ ] down shut that [ __ ]
down I'm gonna get my damn cooking
clothes on I gotta make something to eat
cooking clothes yeah whatever happened
to your chef jacket I got it put up it's
hanging up and it's hanging up one of
these claws I never see you wear it
anymore
it's only when I have guests oh okay
when you gotta like it when I Gotta Go
full [ __ ] when I go we didn't even
fit you anymore like with your big ass
arms now what's that would it even fit
you now with your big ass arms sure I
haven't seen you wear it in a long time
yeah it was it it just occurred to me
that you still had that like that was a
long time ago that you got that for
Christmas it'd fit no problem but yeah
it's a chef jacket all right yeah
all right we're gonna wrap it up uh
Rebecca said thank you for the show I'll
listen to it in full tomorrow hopefully
everybody uh enjoyed it I actually had a
good time like uh with this one this was
actually a good topic so thank you I
think it was Zach that recommended it so
we will be back once again on Friday
night having some drinks and doing the
site track show just talking about
whatever now I think Friday night is
Memento Mori also okay now that I'm
thinking about it so it'll be like a
pre-gaming show because we have to go
out afterward like we did last Friday
but uh yeah thanks everybody for
dropping by thanks for your super chats
and we will see you guys again on Friday
evening good night